la séance est ouverte bonjour à tous
donc l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au gouvernement la première
question sera posée par le groupe elle
est fille par monsieur michel sala
oui bonjour
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs du gouvernement chers
collègues la france suffoque c'est la
deuxième fois en deux mois
la vague de chaleur couple et la
sécheresse sont l'un des vecteurs
d'importance incendie le dérèglement
climatique est là et la réponse du
gouvernement français n'est pas la
hauteur alors que l'europe relève ses
objectifs climatiques pour 2030 nous
perdons un temps précieux dans le gard
ma circonscription et est fortement
touchée autour des villes de bessèges de
gagnières de bord de zac c'est au tour
de la région bordelaise de connaître un
épisode encore plus dramatique avec près
de 17 mille hectares de forêt qui se
sont embrasées fait nouveau d'autres
régions plus au nord sont touchés comme
les monts d'arrée en bretagne ou en pays
de loire l'anjou la vendée la mayenne au
mans à nantes nous adressons aux
dizaines de milliers d'habitants touchés
par ces incendies aux pompiers venus les
protéger toute notre solidarité dans ces
moments graves nous saluons les pilotes
des canadairs exerçant un métier
extrêmement dangereux
les moyens leur manque aujourd'hui pour
assurer leur mission de protection
civile
la flotte d'avions de lutte anti feu
situé à nîmes comprend sur le papier 12
canadair cette date le 14 juillet 2019
ses 19 avions étaient en capacité de
voler aujourd'hui nous régressons seuls
neuf canadair quatre dash vol la
maintenance assurée par l'entreprise pv
s'habille la technique n'est pas au
niveau il y à 16 commandant de bord
alors que 22 sont nécessaires en cause
la politique menée par la direction de
la sécurité civile qui reconnaît
pourtant un dispositif opérationnel
tendu madame la première ministre
mesdames et messieurs du gouvernement à
rebours de l'urgence écologique
vous avez établi depuis 2010 est
affaibli nos opérations public comme
météo france le fb loi nèfles ign en
supprimant près de 15% des effectifs il
faut que cela cesse la flotte d'avions
anti feu et un service public
indispensable à qui vous devez donner
des moyens nouveaux qu'elles flottent
envisagez-vous contre les incendies
quels moyens humains envisagez-vous de
nouvelles implantations de base si nous
voulons sauver lui-même sur mer si ces
nouveaux pieds et tenter de survivre
urinaire si la parole est à monsieur
gérald darmanin ministre de l'intérieur
et des outre-mer
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
je veux d'ailleurs au nom du
gouvernement et comme la première
ministre l'a fait encore très récemment
rendre hommage que vous l'avez fait aux
sapeurs pompiers aux militaires aux élus
aux policiers aux gendarmes qui lutte
depuis le 12 juillet
dans des conditions extrêmement
difficiles
avec un soin et un professionnalisme qui
fait honneur à la france
et monsieur le député je veux souligner
même si effectivement il ya quasiment
désormais 60 kilomètres carrés de feu en
gironde et qu'il ya de très nombreux
autres feux dans les bouches du rhône
dans le finistère 20 feu par jour
aujourd'hui sont constatés sur le
territoire national de très nombreuses
et un dès qu'ils font moins de cinq
hectares mais quelques-uns qui sont
extrêmement impressionnant et qui tue la
biodiversité je veux fait remarquer que
malgré cela l arrêt des jours et des
nuits de sécheresse et de feu il n'ya
touchons du bois si j'ose dire il n'y a
aucun décès ni chez les sapeurs pompiers
ni ni ni chez les 45000 personnes qui
ont été déplacées
je veux dire monsieur le député
cependant que tout ne peut pas être
obligé de la polémique il n'ya pas neuf
canadair que vous l'avez évoqué il n'ya
pas neuf avions il ya 21 avions et 35
hélicoptères nous avons la plus grande
flotte européenne la plus grande flotte
européenne de lutte contre le feu tout
ne peut pas être objet de polémique nous
avons augmenté de 44% le budget de la
sécurité civile dans cinq ans et tout ne
peut pas être objet de polémique nous
avons mobilisé des militaires non peut
nous avons mobilisé des moyens comme
aucun pays européen ne le fait alors
encourageons plutôt l'asapa pompiers
réjouissons-nous qu'il n'y ait pas de
morts réjouissons nous que nous
puissions aujourd'hui avec la sécurité
civile déplacer des personnes sauvées
des animaux sauver des entreprises
plutôt que chercher ici des polémiques
qui n'ont pas lieu d'être merci
la parole est à monsieur yannick neuder
madame la prie madame la présidente mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur munis de la santé nous avons
déjà évoqué dans cet hémicycle
l'éviction des personnels de santé non
vaccinés souligné la situation
paradoxale de faire revenir dans nos
services hospitaliers des personnels
atteints de co vide avec peu de
symptômes mais et en refusant du fait de
la pénurie de personnel en refusant les
personnels sont vaccinés
cette situation est encore pire dans les
ehpad et je voudrais revenir également
sur le sort de nos sapeurs pompiers
c'est très bien de pouvoir les remercier
et les féliciter ça serait encore mieux
si les 5000 pompiers volontaires que
l'on pourrait réintégrer qui sont non
vaccinés mais qui souhaitent pouvoir
participer aux combats du feu notamment
en gironde et en bretagne surtout que
cette éviction repose sur des faits non
scientifique puisqu'on sait que le
vaccin ne protège pas de la
contamination et nous avons une
couverture vaccinale à plus de 95% sur
notre sol donc je renouvelle ma question
de cohérence monsieur le ministre
pourquoi perdre tout ce temps pour
réintégrer des personnels administratifs
soignants médico sociaux dans nos ehpad
dans nos hôpitaux et aux prennent aux
populations qui souffrent de la canicule
et des incendies merci à vous
je vous remercie
la parole est à monsieur françois braun
ministre de la santé de la prévention et
madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député nader
valorisons d'abord le sens citoyen
éthique des personnes qui sont en
contact des français les plus fragiles
c'est aussi la solidarité qui a compté
dans cette crise c'est grâce à la
solidarité que chaque coach de chacun
que nous avons traversé la crise je
pense notamment aux professionnels
mobilisés ils ont accompli leur devoir
avec courage et il faut aussi leur
rendre hommage
je veux ensuite rappelé le sens de
l'obligation vaccinale
elle est destinée aux professionnels en
contact fréquent avec les publics les
plus fragiles
ces professionnels l'ont d'ailleurs bien
compris car ils sont dans leur immense
majorité vacciner pour leur protection
est aussi surtout pour protéger les plus
faciles
en tant que médecin je rappelle dans le
pays de pasteur l'importance de la
vaccination
c'est notre arme de protection massive
elle nous permet de sauver des vies elle
nous a permis de retrouver une vie
normale en sortant des mesures d'urgence
sanitaire les non vaccinés sont peu
nombreux la fhf nous disait par exemple
que cela concerne moins de 500
infirmières sur deux cent soixante trois
mille dans le service public hospitalier
je veux aussi mettre en garde face à ce
que certains pourraient prendre pour une
solution miracle pour résoudre les
problèmes liés au manque de personnel
pour autant j'entends les questions que
vous êtes nombreux à me poser je
souhaite que ce soit la science qui nous
aident à trancher cette question comme
vous l'avez vu l'académie nationale de
médecine s'est par exemple fermement
prononcé contre la réintégration des
professionnels sujet à l'obligation
vaccinale dans un communiqué de ce jour
de plus comme je vous l'avais annoncé
j'ai saisi la haute autorité de santé
dont la vie permettra également déclaré
nos débats à la lumière de leur retour
et comme je me suis engagé nous pourrons
alors objectiver la situation et prendre
une décision éclairée vous remercie
monsieur le d'air
monsieur le ministre vous nous avez
transmis ces chiffres que nous ne
contestons pas mais la réalité terrain
nous appelons nous oblige à plus de
pragmatisme
vous avez ôté a été auteur d'une mission
flash maintenant nous demandons des
choses pragmatique pour permettre à nos
ehpad à nos hôpitaux et à nos pompiers
de pouvoir est bien passé l'été dans les
meilleures conditions les personnels
sont épuisés et je pense que ces mesures
qui n'expose pas les patients qui
peuvent soulager les personnels en place
serait une mesure de bon sens et de
cohérence
je vous remercie
la parole est à monsieur frédéric
valletoux
merci madame la présidente mes chers
collègues cette question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de la transition
écologique et la cohésion des
territoires la france s'embrase en
gironde dans les monts d'arrée à avignon
ou même début juin dans ma
circonscription dans la forêt de
fontainebleau des incendies se
déclenchent dans tout le territoire ils
ne sont plus l'apanage des régions
méditerranéennes et touchent chaque
année de nouveaux massifs jusqu alors
protégé de ce risque je voudrais
d'ailleurs que nous ayons ici une pensée
comme nous l'avons eu un instant pour
nos héros du quotidien nos sapeurs
pompiers nos militaires les agents de la
sécurité civile de l'eau nf les services
des collectivités locales épaulé en
gironde par de nombreux bénévoles en un
mot tout ce qui nous protège et lutte
contre le feu avec courage et dévouement
parfois à d'autres périodes au péril de
leur vie
le stade où la maison brûlait semble
aujourd'hui il est passé devant nos yeux
ce sont bien nos forêts notre
biodiversité nos paysages et finalement
la vie tout court qui se consume le
constat est clair le changement
climatique assèche nos sols et la
végétation et génère une plus grande
récurrence des épisodes de feu un
chiffre doit particulièrement nous
alerter 90% des feux sont dus à
l'imprudence humaine une prise de
conscience nationale sur l'ampleur de ce
risque est indispensable je veux d'abord
salué l'augmentation inédite du budget
de la sécurité civile lors du prince et
lors du précédent quinquennat
44% de plus en cinq ans nous devons
poursuivre et amplifier cet effort
au-delà et c'est l'objet de la question
nous devons également développer les
réponses plus structurelle je pense
notamment à une meilleure application
l'obligation légale de brousse de
débroussaillement à la réalisation
d'aménagements nouveau pour protéger nos
forêts il ya des mesures de prévention
afin d'éviter parfois les conséquences
de la sur-fréquentation la recherche a
aussi mis en évidence les dangers que
représentent les monocultures forestière
alors monsieur le ministre pouvez vous
nous indiquer comment le gouvernement
compte concilier la protection de nos
sites naturels et de la biodiversité
avec les contraintes de prévention
qu'imposer risques liés au réchauffement
climatique et notamment le risque
incendie s'agissant de nos forêts
la parole est un monsieur christophe
béchu ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires
madame la présidente madame la première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
parlementaires monsieur le député
valletoux nous sommes rendus à
effectivement 27 mille hectares de forêt
brûlés avec 3500 départs de feu et je
veux au delà de l'hommage que vous venez
de le rappeler qui vient d'être rendu
par le ministre de l'intérieur salué sur
tous les bancs
précisément revenir sur ce chiffre
90% des départs de feu sont liées à des
mégots sont liées à des barbecues sont
liées à des imprudences humaine et on
peut pas à la fois applaudir nos sapeurs
pompiers et ne pas faire en sorte que
chacun fasse attention à des gestes
élémentaires de prévention sur
l'ensemble de ces sujets
au delà
au-delà de cet appel à la responsabilité
individuelle
il va de soi qu'un certain nombre de
mesures globales doivent être prises
vous avez cité l'obligation de
débroussaillage pour les propriétaires
qui est un vrai sujet je veux saluer la
mission flash qui a été lancée par la
commission de l'aménagement
durables dans cette de l'aménagement du
territoire du développement durable de
l'assemblée nationale je veux également
cité le rapport en préparation sur les
méga-feux qui est fait au sénat qui
devrait rendre des conclusions à
l'automne et qui devrait nous aider à
voir plus clair préciser ce qu'est cette
obligation c'est la mission que la
première ministre a confié au cgedd pour
précisément qu'on puisse préciser les
conditions dans lesquelles ne pouvoir
aller plus loin en termes de
débroussaillage l'autre grand sujet ce
sont les couloirs qui permettent aux
sapeurs pompiers d'intervenir les
couloirs de défense contre les incendies
dans les forêts qui sont gérés par le
rennais 25% du massif forestier national
ces couloirs existe dans les 75 % de
forêts privées il arrive que des
associations d'usagers s'oppose à la
réalisation de ces couloirs pendant
extrêmement complexe l'intervention des
secours pompiers et donc mesdames et
messieurs
sur l'essai sur un sujet dans une villa
ne résoudra rien merci monsieur le
ministre merci
j'ai la parole est à monsieur thibault
françois
jacquot
merci madame la présidente chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
catherine colonna ministre de l'europe
et des affaires étrangères nous avons
appris le 12 juillet dernier dans le
journal la tribune que le gouvernement
était prêt à livrer du gaz à l'allemagne
au nom d'une soi disant tu solidarité
européenne alors madame la ministre au
moment où des millions de familles ne
peuvent plus utiliser leur voiture ne se
chauffent plus correctement et doit
faire face à une augmentation des prix
alimentaires vous plier aux règles
dictées par l'allemagne et par l'union
européenne alors d'après l'insee dans ma
circonscription le douaisis c'est plus
de 80% des ménages qui utilisent leur
voiture quotidiennement pour se rendre
sur leur lieu de travail alors loin de
votre des connexions ces gens là comme
vous dites souffrent chaque jour et
doivent limiter leurs déplacements à
cause des carburants qui atteignent des
prix délirants les folies de ce
gouvernement n'ont plus de limites nous
sommes à peine en suffisance énergique
tiff énergétique à tel point que vous
êtes contraints de rouvrir des centrales
à charbon vous arrivez même a explosé
les quotas de co2 que vous étiez
vous-même fixez vous abandonner une fois
de plus un pan de notre souveraineté de
notre indépendance en vous pliant au
modèle allemand pour des raisons que
nous ignorons tous encore une fois
madame la ministre vous et votre
gouvernement est totalement déconnectés
des attentes et des réalités des
français notre énergie nous coûte une
fortune vous la vendez à nos voisins
vous imposer des sanctions à des pays
belligérants dont seuls les français
souffrent alors ma question est la
suivante comment allez-vous pallier le
manque de gaz pour les français à
l'automne et à l'hiver prochain et me
confirmez vous que le gouvernement
envisage de livrer du gaz à l'allemagne
alors que vous n'avez même pas
l'assurance d'en avoir suffisamment pour
les français je remercie
vous remercie
la parole est à madame agnès pannier
vaunage ministre de la transition
énergétique
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les députés
merci de poser cette question monsieur
le député françois parce que votre
question est pour le moins confuse et
met le doute dans l'esprit des français
la réalité est que ce gouvernement a
d'abord protéger le français sur les
coûts d énergie et permettez moi de
rappeler que cette protection sur le
coût des énergies c'est 30 milliards
d'euros qui va directement dans la poche
des français je crois que vos
propositions ne sont pas la maille de
cet effort que nous avons fait depuis
l'automne dernier deuxièmement
s'agissant des exportations et des
importations d'énergie je vous rappelle
que grâce au marché européen
nous bénéficions 40 jours par an de la
livraison d'électricité de nos voisins
européens
est ce que votre proposition consiste
mais je veux juste le comprendre est ce
que votre proposition consiste à faire
le black out par les français en
refusant l'électricité européenne et
c'est très exactement cette solidarité
européenne en matière d'énergie qui fait
que nous serons en situation de livrer
du gaz que nous avons aujourd'hui si les
allemands n'ont besoin je rappelle
également mais vous avez l'air de
l'ignorer qu'en matière industrielle
si l'industrie allemande s'effondrent
c'est l'ensemble de l'industrie
européenne qui s'effondrera avec les
cortèges l'emploi qui va avec vous êtes
du douaisis est ce que vous connaissez
les filières industrielles qui font
fonctionner les entreprises
industrielles du douaisis et qui
dépendent notamment d'entreprises
allemandes alors foin de démagogie nous
avons mis en place des stocks
énergétique pour faire face aux ruptures
d'approvisionnement de gaz nous avons un
plan nous serons prêts
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à monsieur tu es ma taille
legayic
mater
merci madame la présidente madame la
première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres chers collègues yoran hier
deux grands absents du projet de loi sur
la protection du pouvoir d'achat les
outre-mer et les jeunes je vais donc
aborder le thème de la précarité
étudiante en polynésie l'enseignement
supérieur étant de compétence d'état en
polynésie seuls 30 à 35 pour cent des
néo bachelier accèdent aux études
supérieures c'est deux fois moins qu'en
france la raison en est que le système
éducatif n'est pas adapté aux réalités
polynésienne nos étudiants font face à
un manque et une eva captation des
filets à proposer dans le pays et les
obligeant à partir ou à choisir des
filières par dépit de plus une majorité
d'étudiants polynésiens n'a pas les
moyens financiers de partir en france
pour suivre des études de chiffres
papeete paris 18 mille km 22 heures de
vol de 1500 euros photo iw à tahiti une
huit bateaux quatre heures de vol 1000
euros qui plus est nombre de jeunes
n'ont pas accès à la bouche ni aux prêts
bancaires les bourses sont insuffisantes
ne dépassant pas les 500 euros et pour
les prêts bancaires étudiants le taux
d'intérêt est à 3 9% telle est au dessus
de cette france ainsi quand on a de la
chance que ces jeunes n'arrêtent pas
leurs études ils cherchent des petits
boulots pour se nourrir et sont parfois
obligées de se prostituer
ainsi madame la première ministre quelle
est votre position concrète sur les
mesures suivantes pour la polynésie les
outre-mer où la france mise en place
d'un revenu d'autonomie de 120 mille
francs passe on est encore en francs à
destination des étudiants baisse et gel
du taux d'intérêt des prêts étudiants
élargissement des étudiants éligibles au
prêt garanti par l'état augmentation de
50 à 75% de la prise en charge du billet
d'avion au titre du dispositif passeport
mobilité à destination des familles
éligibles et élargissement des critères
d'obtention à la prise en charge à 100 %
afin que plus de familles puissent en
bénéficier
ma routine
je vous remercie
la parole est à madame sylvie retailleau
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche
la président a si ça marche madame la
présidente monsieur madame les députés
monsieur le député le gaz d'abord je
voudrais vous remercier pour cette
première question pour les étudiants et
en particulier d'outre-mer et polynésie
française et de remettre effectivement
les problématiques de vie étudiante et
de conditions de vie étudiante au coeur
et plus particulièrement chez vous en
polynésie française alors je vous ai
évoqué plusieurs points d'abord la non
d'adaptation vous avez parlé du premier
cycle je voudrais juste dire que d'abord
de façon générale le premier site va
être une priorité dans la politique que
l'on va revoir et en particulier le
premier cycle en outre-mer et en
polynésie je voudrais juste ne sais pas
si vous le savez mais vous apprendre que
j'ai annoncé un projet de 11 millions
d'euros qui a été attribuée à
l'université de polynésie française la
semaine dernière justement basées sur le
premier cycle en particulier adapté à
l'économie locale mais aussi aux enjeux
de développement durable si important
dans votre il est au niveau de la
polynésie française donc ça c'est un
premier point et que l'on suivra
vraiment avec attention le deuxième
point c'est l'aide de la vie étudiante
donc il ya eu évidemment les aides que
l'on a annoncé de façon conjoncturelle
comme tous les étudiants peut-être deux
points je vais pas les rappeler vous
avez la revalorisation de 4% des bourses
mais effectivement pour les boursiers
polynésien est bien le fait qu'il puisse
avoir douze mois par rapport à 10 mois
classiquement pour profiter de ces
bourses est lié soit aux difficultés
insulaire soit aux difficultés liées à
l'éloignement et vous avez parlé des
études fait en france sur ce point
particulier nous avons étudié essayé de
mener nous allons le faire une des
mesures volontaristes sur les
déplacements des étudiants polynésiens
et aussi de la nouvelle calédonie sur
ces problématiques là et pour la rentrée
nous avons rajouté deux points de charge
pour les bourses pour les étudiants qui
se concentre surtout polynésiens et
calédoniens qui pourront être ajoutés à
la rentrée par rapport aux difficultés
de l'éloignement et croyez moi nous
allons suivre cela avec beaucoup
d'attention comme l'ensemble des
conditions pour les la vie étudiante je
vous remercie je vous remercie monsieur
le gagner
merci madame la ministre pour ses
réponses et j'espère que vous allez
mettre un point d'honneur parce que les
chiffres c'est 50 %
des jeunes ont moins de 35 ans est aussi
50% qui vit sous le seuil de pauvreté et
ses 55 50 % qui vont dans les points
soit son niveau voilà ma joue je le
remercie la parole est un monsieur
guillaume kasbarian
merci madame la présidente
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'économie des finances et
de la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique la semaine dernière se tenait
la cinquième édition du sommet de shoes
france l'occasion d'accueillir les
investisseurs du monde entier qui
choisissent de s'implanter en france ils
sont nombreux à le faire puisque pour la
troisième année consécutive notre pays
est le premier choix des investisseurs
étrangers en europe ce sont quatorze
nouveaux investissements étrangers qui
vont créer 4000 emplois dans nos
circonscriptions
ces bons résultats ne tombent pas du
ciel ils viennent d'une politique
industrielle conquérante avec des
réformes de structure et une baisse
inédite de la fiscalité plus de 50
milliards d'euros de baisses d'impôts
pour regagner en compétitivité et cela
fonctionne puisque les créations
d'emplois sont au plus haut et le
chômage au plus bas
alors oui
des entreprises réalisent des bénéfices
dans notre pays certaines plus que
d'autres mais tout paye déjà aujourd'hui
des impôts en proportion de leurs
bénéfices elle en paye plus qu'ailleurs
puisque la france reste toujours la
championne des prélèvements obligatoires
en europe juste après le danemark cela
ne semble pas inquiéter certaine
opposition qui réclame une nouvelle taxe
additionnelle sur les profits mais le
sujet n'est pas de remplir les caisses
de l'état avec de nouvelles taxes le
sujet c'est d'encourager les entreprises
à mieux distribuer leurs bénéfices avec
leurs salariés le sujet c'est d'inciter
les entreprises qui réalisent des marges
importantes à baisser les prix qui
pèsent sur les consommateurs la taxe
n'est pas la solution magique pour
répondre aux attentes légitimes des
salariés et des consommateurs
monsieur le ministre les grands groupes
bénéficiaires doivent s'engager pour un
meilleur partage de la valeur au regard
de vos premières discussions avec eux
quelles sont les avancées que vous
pouvez nous communiquer je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est un
monsieur bruno le maire ministre de
l'économie des finances et de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
député cabariot mesdames et messieurs
les députés monsieur le député merci de
rappeler une évidence
la politique de baisse des impôts sur
les entreprises que nous avons
entreprise depuis cinq ans donne des
résultats
nous allons baisser l'impôt des sociétés
que nous avons ramené de 33 2 3 25 % la
moyenne européenne nous avons supprimé
la taxe sur l'intéressement et nous
avons engagé pour la première fois la
baisse des impôts de production
résultats 1,3 million d'emplois
supplémentaires au cours du quinquennat
le chômage qui baisse des usines qui
rouvre 2,4 millions de salariés couverts
par un tel accord d'intéressement au
lieu de 1,5 ses résultats ce sont les
vôtres et ce sont ceux qui résulte de la
baisse des impôts la fiscalité des
prélèvement des taxes des entreprises
ans je le dis à toutes les députés tous
les députés de la majorité ne perdons
pas le fil rouge de notre politique
économique tel qu'il a été rappelé par
la première ministre nous devons
poursuivre la baisse des impôts pour nos
compatriotes est ce que pour autant cela
exonère les entreprises de participer la
protection des françaises et des
français contre les ravages de
l'inflation certainement pas nous
l'avons déjà dit à plusieurs reprises
les entreprises qui le peuvent doivent
augmenter les salaires de leurs salariés
des entreprises doit se saisir des
accords d'intéressement de participation
elles doivent utiliser la prime
défiscalisées et toutes celles qui font
des bénéfices doivent rendre une partie
de leurs bénéfices directement à nos
compatriotes car je préfère que l'argent
aille dans la poche de nos compatriotes
plutôt que dans la poche de l'état avec
de nouvelles taxes
alors nous ferons les comptes à la fin
de l'année
nous verrons ces entreprises pétrolières
ces entreprises des transports si les
banques les assurances ont fait
suffisamment pour nos compatriotes je
vais vous donner ma conviction profonde
aujourd'hui la réponse est non mais il
leur reste encore quelques mois pour
faire davantage pour le pouvoir d'achat
nos compatriotes pour les protéger
davantage contre l'inflation je compte
sur elle nous ferons les comptes
la parole est à monsieur jérôme guedj un
merci madame la présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la première ministre
le réchauffement climatique nous le
savons frappe d'abord les plus fragiles
la canicule de 2003 ces dix neuf mille
morts essentiellement des personnes
âgées très souvent isolés est là pour
nous le rappeler cruellement transition
démographique et transition écologique
sont donc des combats convergent
malheureusement il y a des trous dans la
raquette dans notre système de politique
publique depuis 2004 vous le savez les
communes doivent tenir des registres des
personnes vulnérables pour aller à leur
contact en période exceptionnelle
problème trop peu de personnes âgées
font la démarche volontaire de
s'inscrire sur ces registres la solution
existe elle est connue elle a été
proposée en 2020 permettre le partage
des informations entre les conseils
départementaux les caisses de retraite
et les ccs notamment pour connaître les
bénéficiaires de l'apa et de la pch sur
le territoire communal le gouvernement
avait donné son accord mais faute de
l'oat grand âge et autonomie elle n'a
pas pu être mises en oeuvre ma première
question est simple souhaitez vous
mettre en oeuvre cette disposition pour
muscler les registres canicule dans les
villes et au delà de la canicule car ce
ne sont pas les chaleurs extrêmes qui
tue mais bien souvent d'isolement il
faut construire une politique pérenne de
lutte contre ce fléau social en
mobilisant les conseils départementaux
les ccs les associations comme les
petits frères des pauvres
la croix rouge les bailleurs sociaux la
poste les services d'aidé à domicile et
professionnels de santé pour repérer les
fragilités et aller au devant de ces
populations
invisible et oublier tout cela doit
s'inscrire dans une politique
interministérielle du vieillissement
dans le précédent quinquennat beaucoup
de rapports beaucoup de missions
beaucoup de travaux parlementaires de
grandes car ils qualité mais au final
pas de loi ma deuxième question madame
la ministre s'est il y as sur tous les
bancs de cette assemblée sur presque
tous les bancs beaucoup de
parlementaires motivé pour construire
non pas uniquement une loi grand âge et
autonomie mais ils ont un panoramique
sur la longévité qui nous permettra
d'aborder cette révolution
anthropologique essentiel pour notre
société êtes vous prêt à laisser les
parlementaires construire cette loi
d'orientation pour la longévité je vous
remercie je vous remercie
la parole est à monsieur jean christophe
conte ministre des solidarités de
l'autonomie et des personnes handicapées
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
jérôme guedj merci pour cette première
question je crois que comme moi j'en
suis persuadé vous avez acquis la
conviction profonde que l' isolement
social tue dans notre société en
particulier les personnes les plus
fragiles c'est en tout cas ce que vous
avez démontré dans le rapport que vous
avez remis début 2020
olivier vers ans et je crois qu on ne
peut pas construire une société
résiliente sans créer renforcer le lien
social au sein de notre société je me
suis beaucoup déplacé c'est derniers
jours et j'ai pu constater sur le
terrain la mobilisation exceptionnelle
de l'ensemble des acteurs du grand âge
dans les établissements à domicile dans
les ccas et pas plus tard que ce midi
j'étais d'ailleurs à meudon où j'ai pu
participer à une séance d'appel du ccas
vers des personnes isolées à domicile et
je crois qu'il faut effectivement
développer l'utilisation des registres
communaux qui ont été rendus
obligatoires par la loi du 30 rue du 30
juin 2004 par votre proposition qui
consiste à intégrer directement dans ce
registre les bénéficiaires de l'apa et
de la pch vous en avez fait la
proposition dans ce rapport mérite
encore un examen approfondi vous l'avez
dit on a besoin d'une modification
jce l'atvs pour pouvoir y répondre
on a besoin de continuer à examiner la
faisabilité de ces dispositifs notamment
au regard de la question sensible de la
protection des données personnelles et
donc nous allons continuer à y
travailler
moi ce que je vous propose c'est que
éventuellement en phase d
expérimentation sur les territoires là
où les départements et les communes
seraient d'accord et ces mesures
s'intégreront dans une vision plus large
de la société du bien vieillir c'est la
feuille de route que le président la
république et la première ministre m'ont
donné et on aura à coeur avec vous de
construire ce cadre les personnes âgées
strahl
je veux demanderaient s'il vous plaît
d'être un petit peu plus silencieux il
ya un brouhaha continue qui je trouve
perturbe les questions et les réponses
la parole est à madame ségolène à millau
madame la présidente madame la première
ministre je suis de ces gens là il ya
dix ans j'étais vice présidente du
centre lgbt de nantes et nous souffrions
alors les agressions lgbt fob mais
surtout de leur non qualification
juridique
il ya un mois après la praille de nantes
un jeune s'est fait agressé par cinq
hommes en rentrant chez lui il avait un
drapeau arc en ciel dans les cheveux il
a porté plainte mais la qualification
homophobes a été refusée au profit de
faits crapuleux alors que rien ne lui
avait été volé il a été agressé parce
que présumé gain en 10 ans les
agressions n'ont pas diminué les
personnes lgbt se font toujours agressé
dans la rue et le motif d'homophobie et
trop souvent refusée par la police en
deux ans les agressions lgbt fob ont
augmenté de 20% les formations de la
police sur les lgbt phobies existe
heureusement mais elles sont
insuffisantes la police manque de moyens
et de formation et ces manquements mes
chers collègues ont des conséquences
réelles sur la vie des personnes
discriminées
mais comment leur en vouloir quand le
gouvernement est loin d'être exemplaire
comment leur en vouloir quand plusieurs
ministres enchaîne les déclarations
homophobes et sexistes
comment croire en une police exemplaires
alors que le gouvernement ne l'est pas
la liste des déclarations homophobes est
trop longue béchu darmanin et bien sûr
cayeux qui affirme toujours son mépris
des homosexuels je vous le rappelle au
cas où mesdames et messieurs les
ministres l'homophobie n'est pas une
opinion c'est un délit
comment comptez vous madame la première
ministre appliquez l'exemplarité en
france alors que des membres de votre
gouvernement et de la manif pour tous
sont toujours coincés au siècle passé
sur les lgbt phobies je vous remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à mme adam et isabelle
rheault ministre déléguée chargée de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
de la diversité et de l'égalité des
chances
madame la présidente
mesdames messieurs les parlementaires
madame la députée amyot tout d'abord
j'aimerais commencer par avoir une
pensée pour toutes ces victimes en
particulier
cette personne qui a été agressé hier à
béton vous visez des ministres vous en
vous avez vous avez particulièrement
visé une ministre elle s'est excusée
et aujourd'hui elle est pleinement à la
tâche aux côtés d'elisabeth board
s'agissant de la s'agissant s'agissant
de la lutte pour les lgbt phobies nous
n'avons pas à rougir de notre bilan qui
a couvert
qui a ouvert à la paix est mort à toutes
les femmes qui a interdit les thérapies
de conversion qui à faire évoluer le don
du sang
qui a généralisé l'accès de la prep aux
médecins généralistes
qui a facilité l'utilisation du prénom
usage dans les documents administratifs
qui a permis la formation de plus de 20
mille policiers et gendarmes qui a créé
des postes spécifiques d'officiers de
liaison dans les commissariats et les
gendarmeries
c'est la majorité parlementaire c'est
vous
alors évidemment oui le mot phobie n'est
pas une opinion c'est un délit il nous
faut continuer hajji a lutté avec le mes
collègues ministre de l'intérieur
ministre de la justice je réunirai à la
rentrée le comité de suivi du plan lgbt
du gouvernement car oui il s'agit d'un
combat pour l'égalité
face à la montée des conservatismes
il nous faut agir vite je vous remercie
ma droite ljr fort mais résignée la
ministre
madame la ministre vous avez écoulée
votre temps je vous remercie
madame amyot
madame la ministre on ne peut pas
s'excuser dans des lits on est accusé
d'un délit d'une part d'autre part je
vous rappellerai que les augmentations
continue d'augmenter 20 % comme je
voulais dis moi j'attends madame la
première ministre que vous l'y mme
augier vos ministres homophobes et que
vous formiez la police
la parole
la parole est à madame cécile reilhac
merci madame la présidente
ma question s'adresse au ministre de
l'éducation nationale et j'y associe
stella dupont graziella melchior ainsi
que mes collègues de la majorité
monsieur le ministre vous le savez
depuis 2010 est des mesures de grande
ampleur ont été déployés afin
d'accompagner au mieux la scolarité de
l'ensemble de nos élèves et notamment
ceux à besoins particuliers
permettre à l'école de la république
d'être pleinement inclusive est une
ambition forte de notre majorité qui a
fait du handicap une priorité afin de
parvenir à cet objectif le rôle des
accompagnants des élèves en situation de
handicap les ash est déterminant depuis
2010 9 grâce au travail constructif des
parlementaires de la majorité comme de
l'opposition
les ars h bénéficient de contrats d'une
durée de trois ans renouvelable une fois
désormais ils peuvent accéder au cdi
permettez moi permettez moi chers
collègues de vous rappeler qu'avant 2017
les ados un sage qu'on appelait à
l'époque les assistants vie scolaire les
avs et ai souvent sous contrat
d'insertion d'un an ou contractuels de
la fonction publique monsieur le
ministre nos efforts doivent
impérativement se poursuivre et je sais
votre détermination à oeuvrer à nos
côtés dans ce sens vous le savez
beaucoup reste à faire certains
établissements scolaires et
collectivités territoriales nous
alertent régulièrement sur les
difficultés de recrutement alors que
nous avons voté un budget conséquent
pour le recrutement des as hb l'an passé
poursuivre l'amélioration des conditions
de travail des usa est indispensable
pour respecter notre engagement en
faveur d'une école plus inclusive et
plus juste la question est donc simple
sinistre comment renforcer
l'attractivité du métier des sages
favoriser le recrutement et ainsi
améliorer encore la scolarisation des
enfants à besoins particuliers
je vous remercie
mes chers collègues il n'y a pas que vos
questions qui méritent d'être écoutés
j'aimerais que chacun puisse écouter
l'ensemble des questions qui sont posées
dans cet hémicycle
la parole est monsieur est un monsieur
pape ndiaye ministre de l'éducation et
de la formation professionnelle
madame madame la présidente
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
la députée riac les conditions de
travail des ash sont en effet
déterminante pour la qualité et
l'effectivité de la scolarisation des
enfants en situation de handicap et
c'est également un enjeu social évident
nous mobilisons aujourd'hui près de 120
milles aes h qui permettent la
scolarisation d'environ 410 mille
enfants en situation de handicap un
nombre d'arrêts sage qui a crû de 50%
entre 2017 et 2022 les efforts
budgétaires ont été consentis cette
année comme l'année précédente et nous
pouvons dire que nous allons recruter
environ 4000 ash pour la rentrée à venir
mais vous avez raison nous devons
améliorer l'attractivité du métier ash
pour cela nous procédons d'abord à la
multiplication des recrutements en cdd
d'une durée de trois ans nous avons
également la possibilité d'accès au cdi
au bout de six ans d'exercice l'accès
aux droits à formation professionnelle
et aux prestations d'action sociale une
grille indiciaire aussi a été créé pour
automatiser leur avancement enfin les
1es h bénéficieront des mesures
relatives au point d' indice prévu par
le projet de loi en matière de la
protection
je revois d'achat ce sont des progrès
réels mais nous avons parlé tous les
noirs un effort supplémentaire
un effort supplémentaire pour
revaloriser les carrières va être engagé
dans le cadre du projet de loi de
finances il faut améliorer durablement
les conditions de travail des os h et
c'est ce à quoi je m'engage c'est
beaucoup monsieur le ministre
monsieur rufin ce que vous pouvez cessé
d'interpeller continuellement le
ministre quand il parle et lomé
vinci il ya des règles dans cet
hémicycle deux minutes de questions 2010
de réponse ans
[Applaudissements]
donc la parole et à madame caroline
parmentier
allez-y clegg
merci madame la présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'économie et
des finances monsieur le ministre depuis
des mois la situation économique de
notre pays se dégrade le prix de
l'énergie augmentent l'inflation sévit
le coût du quotidien devient intenable
partout sur le terrain et notamment dans
ma circonscription de béthune et ses 32
communes nos concitoyens nos alertes sur
leurs difficultés à boucler les fins de
mois des français qui n'arrivent plus à
payer à la fois leur plein d'essence
leur facture d'électricité à remplir
leurs caddies la facture du fameux
chariot-test lequel consiste à acheter
exactement les mêmes produits chaque
mois dans les mêmes enseignes vole de
record en record des français qui
doivent choisir entre se soigner se
chauffer et acheter des vêtements à
leurs enfants des français qui
travaillent et qui n'arrivent pas à
vivre de leurs salaires des français
pour qu'ils allaient travailler coûte de
l'argent à cause du prix de leur
carburant ce n'est pas vivable et vous
ne devez pas l'accepter la solution ne
réside pas seulement dans les chèques et
les exonérations
il faut des solutions pérennes
écouter l'opposition nous avons des
propositions concrètes la majorité des
français les soutiennent avec une baisse
de la tva sur les dépenses d'énergie et
une suppression de la tva sur les
produits de première nécessité vous
pouvez re donner une respiration
financière immédiate aux français il
faut une réponse urgente
vous avez déjà beaucoup trop attendu
monsieur le ministre ma question dès
lors est simple allez vous oui ou non
entendre la détresse des français
comment votre gouvernement compte-t-il
se montrer à la hauteur de la situation
je vous remercie
la parole est un monsieur bruno le maire
ministre de l'économie des finances et
de la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique
madame la présidente des dames et
messieurs les députés mal à mes députés
parmentier
pourquoi croyez vous que nous avons
déposé un projet de loi est un projet de
loi de finances rectificative pour le
pouvoir d'achat des français sinon parce
que nous avons conscience de la détresse
de millions de nos compatriotes
confronter leurs problèmes de pouvoir
d'achat
pourquoi croyez vous que nous avons mis
en place dès le mois de septembre et
d'octobre 2000 21
avant tous les autres pays européens
et de manière beaucoup plus massive que
tous les autres pays européens sans
exception
un gel du prix du gaz vous parliez
légitimement du prix du gaz et un
plafonnement des prix de l'électricité
vous parliez légitimement des prix de
l'électricité sinon pour protéger nos
compatriotes les prix du gaz auraient dû
augmenter de 50% depuis janvier 0 %
d'augmentation les prix de l'électricité
aurait dû augmenter de 35% 4 % seulement
grâce au bouclier tarifaires et à notre
détermination à protéger nos
compatriotes contre les ravages de
l'inflation
nous examinons aujourd'hui à un nouveau
texte dans lequel il ya des propositions
de revalorisation
revalorisation du point d'indicé
revalorisation des retraites car les
retraités sont sans doute parmi les plus
touchées par l'inflation
revalorisation des minima sociaux y
compris les prestations familiales parce
que les familles sont particulièrement
touchés par l'augmentation des prix
alimentaires propositions sur les
carburants et j'ai dit que j'étais
ouvert à toutes les propositions
d'amélioration de nos propositions sur
les carburants sous réserve que ça ne se
solde pas par des dizaines de milliards
d'euros de dépenses supplémentaires et
que ce ne soit pas une subvention
définitive pérennes comme vous dites aux
énergies fossiles et dans ce cadre là
nous sommes prêts je le redis à étudier
toutes les propositions des propositions
pour améliorer notre texte le seul point
de divergence que j'aurai avec vous
c'est sur la tva la baisse de la tva
cette injuste inefficace et coûteux pour
les finances publiques
pour les finances publiques parce que
jacou du milliard d'euros mais
inefficace parce que c'est les
distributeurs qui prennent la marge et
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
madame
donc la parole est à madame justin gruel
merci madame la présidente
mesdames messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse
également à monsieur le ministre de
l'économie et des finances monsieur le
ministre nous le répétons le prix des
carburants reste bien trop élevé et pèse
énormément sur le pouvoir d'achat des
français plus encore dans le monde rural
où la voiture est indispensable
déplacements quotidiens
je le vois chez moi dans le jura nous
sommes obligés de faire souvent
plusieurs dizaines de kilomètres pour
aller au travail pour emmener nos
enfants à l'école pour consulter un
médecin quand nous avons la chance d'en
trouver un pour une famille avec enfants
avec un plein de 90 euros voire deux par
semaine pour le couple on ne s'en sort
pas les conditions vous proposer pour le
futur chèque carburant inquiète déjà
tous nos territoires celles et ceux qui
travaillent dur et qui font l'effort de
se lever tous les matins vont une
nouvelle fois être exclues de ce
dispositif
nous nous voulons soutenir la france qui
travaille c'est pourquoi les députés et
l'air sont force de proposition
lorsqu'il s'agit de redonner du pouvoir
d'achat par le mérite et ne pas
pénaliser ceux qui n'ont pas de moyen de
substitution à la voiture
revenons un tarif raisonnable des
carburants
nous vous faisons des propositions pour
financer ces mesures
notamment par des économies importantes
dans le fonctionnement bien trop lourd
de nos administrations monsieur le
ministre cette baisse des prix du
carburant ne doit pas être réservé à
seulement quelques-uns comme vous le
prévoyez dans votre projet de loi elle
doit bénéficier à tous pour ne surtout
pas oublier les classes moyennes vous
vous dit prêt à entendre nos
propositions et bien là vous en avez
l'occasion ma question est donc simple
êtes vous prêt à entendre cette demande
et à renoncer à une mesure 6 li en
brisant en descendent les prix à la
pompe pour tous
je vous remercie la parole est à
monsieur bruno le maire ministre de
l'économie des finances et de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
oui madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
si j'étais un tout petit peu taquin dans
cette assemblée qui est parfois un petit
peu violente dans ses réparties
j'observerai qu'il ya légère
contradiction dans vos propositions
entre dire qu'il faut soutenir d'abord
ceux qui travaillent et qui n'ont pas
d'autre choix que d'utiliser leur
voiture pour aller travailler et
soutenir l'ensemble de nos compatriotes
il faut choisir mais laissons la
taquinerie de côté et regardons plutôt
le problème réel que vous soulevez oui
pour des millions de nos compatriotes
le prix de l'essence et des carburants
est insupportable oui vous avez des
millions de salariés aujourd'hui qui
renonce à aller sur le lieu de travail
des alternants qui ne peuvent pas aller
en alternance parce que le prix du
carburant est trop élevé nous avons
apporté un certain nombre de réponses
est-ce que nous pouvons les améliorer
est-ce que nous sommes butés sur nos
réponses en disant c'est à prendre ou à
laisser non
non non et trois fois non nous sommes
ouverts à des compromis sur l'ensemble
des propositions que nous avons faites
dans le cadre que nous avons déjà
rappelé avec la première ministre
respecté nos finances publiques rien
faire qui soit dommageable pour le
climat et favoriser effectivement ceux
qui travaillent dans ce cadre là c'est
le groupe l'est républicain a des
propositions à faire pour améliorer le
dispositif sur les carburants nous
sommes prêts à les écouter de manière
constructive j'ajoute un autre point
puisque vous parlez des déplacements
domicile travail
c'est très bien que l'état ait de nos
compatriotes mais il faut que les
entreprises aussi sur les déplacements
domicile travail prennent leur part du
fardeau sur le remboursement des
déplacements de nos compatriotes qui
travaillent nous sommes prêts là aussi
si vous avez des propositions
d'amélioration des dispositifs à
reprendre les propositions pour vous
nous ferez vous le voyez on ne peut pas
être plus constructif et ouvert au
compromis dès lors que cela sert nos
compatriotes et ceux qui travaillent
elle aimerait plutôt que de vouloir des
recettes supplémentaires essayez plutôt
de baisser les dépenses publiques s'il
vous plaît
la parole est à madame sophie mette
merci madame la présidente point
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur
j'associe mais que mes collègues
girondins à cette question le massif
forestier des landes de gascogne brûlent
les feux sont particulièrement violent
dans les secteurs de landiras et de la
teste de buch qu'il s'agisse de forêt
usagère ou à visée économique la forêt
brûle aussi en finistère monts d'arrée
et dans le sud-est de gigantesques feux
ont ravagé presque 19 milles 370 ha à
cette heure de végétation soit presque
deux fois la surface de paris malgré les
importants moyens déployés un troisième
feu s'est déclaré hier dans le médoc des
évacuations préventives des communes
sont réaliser vous même monsieur le
ministre
madame la secrétaire d'état bérengère
couillard et le président du sénat
gérard larcher se sont rendus sur place
et je vous en remercie
je tiens bien sûr à saluer aussi devant
vous tous chers collègues le dévouement
extraordinaire des élus locaux des mères
leurs conseillers municipaux des
services de l'état du département de la
région nouvelle aquitaine
évidemment le travail des soldats du feu
qui est tout simplement et oraux
héroïque de jour comme de nuit
merci pour eux un mot également pour les
forestiers qui ont mis à disposition
leur équipe les hommes leur matériel
pour combattre le feu mais aussi ne
l'oublions pas la préfète buccio les
sous-préfets furie fériés loustics qui
sont exceptionnelles la sécurité civile
adf ces îlots nf tout simplement les
citoyens et la formidable solidarité
entre tous ont travaillé de jour comme
de nuit notre devoir est d'agir pour la
suite face aux grands feux des actions
de prévention sont essentiels il faut
apprendre à retrouver des usages
respectueux de la forêt former les
citoyens sanctionner durement les actes
criminels notons aussi que les moyens
d'aider ce 10 si précieux s'appuie sur
une cartographie qui date de 2002 et qui
méritent d'être mises à jour avec
l'accroissement de la population
collègues je vous remercie
monsieur gérald darmanin ministre de
l'intérieur et des outre-mer
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
je veux redire après votre intervention
comme j'ai fait pour votre collègue tout
notre soutien sapin bon pied bien sûr en
gironde où vous êtes élu et j'ai eu
l'occasion de vous croiser lors de ma
venue au début de ces grands feux mais
pardon mais également dans toute la
france puisque au moment où nous parlons
il ya cinq feux très important 3 en
gironde mais le troisième que vous avez
évoqué vient d'être fixé comme on dit et
donc ne pourra pas se propager davantage
et deux autres feux l'un dans le
finistère et l'autre dans les bouches du
rhône ce qui prouve d'ailleurs que la
sécheresse aliot réchauffement
climatique montre que c'est au nord de
la loire aussi il y en a eu dans le
maine et loire il n'y a pas si longtemps
que ça des feux importants est ce que
nous comprenons des feux de gironde
qu'il soit d'ailleurs d'origine humaine
puisque vous avez vu qu'une personne a
été interpellée et qui seraient
potentiellement pyromane mais
indépendamment de l'origine de ce feu
nous savons que cette sécheresse et sur
achat fonds climatique val ferret dans
des départements qui n'ont pas
l'habitude des feux importants et ce qui
se passe autant gironde et est
exceptionnel puisque le dernier grand
feu daté d'il ya plusieurs années
c'était 700 hectares nous sommes à 20
milles dans votre département depuis
quatre jours et sans doute faut-il
réfléchir au lendemain évidemment faut
laisser travailler les sapeurs-pompiers
maintenant mais au lendemain de ces feux
de cette saison des feux faut-il
réfléchir que l'a très bien dit
christophe béchu à la demande de la
première ministre à la question sécurité
civile sécheresse sécurité civile
réchauffement climatique le psy moyen
des dix moyens aériens le la présidence
française de l'union européenne a permis
d'abord le financement madame et
messieurs les députés à 100% désormais
des achats de canadairs et deux dash ce
sera l'union européenne merci l'europe
c'est grâce à elle que nous arrivons à
intervenir dans la sécurité civile on
peut aussi dire merci à l'europe on
n'est pas obligé d'être bêtement anti
européen s'est pas c'est pas une
obligation
et on peut se réjouir que c'est à la
base de nîmes c'est à la base de nîmes
et évidemment sur tout le territoire
national que
[Musique]
la parole est à madame estelle youssoufa
merci madame la présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères
madame la ministre j'étais ce 14 juillet
à mayotte territoire dont je suis la
représentante je tenais à vous
raconterez avec quelle ferveur quel
patriotisme notre fête nationale il ya
été célébré mayotte est fière d'être
française depuis 1841
pour nous mahorais la fête a
malheureusement été gâchée nous avons vu
le président de la république des
comores azali assoumani et son ministre
des sports a cueilli et embrasser en
tribune d'honneur à quelques pas d'ici
place de la rep delà de la concorde
place de la concorde les ors de la
république brillé de mille feux pour
azali assoumani qui revendique la
souveraineté comoriennes sur mayotte
devant les nations unies et les colonnes
du figaro monsieur azali qui acceptent
les aides financières de paris mais
refuse de reconnaître notre choix de
rester français monsieur attali qui
encourage sinon orchestre l'affût
migratoires qui de l'avis des précédents
gouvernements
déstabilise complètement mayotte et qui
empêche toute politique publique
monsieur attali qui refuse par ailleurs
à nos sportifs mahorais et français
l'honneur et la gloire de chanter la
marseillaise et de porter nos couleurs
nationales lors des rencontres sportives
monsieur attali qui porte la candidature
des comores à l'organisation des jeux
des îles en 2027 alors que mayotte est
candidate pour accueillir cet événement
candidature annoncée depuis plusieurs
années le conseil départemental de
mayotte attend d'ailleurs depuis
plusieurs mois la réponse de l'état pour
sa demande de cofinancement des jeux et
ainsi pouvoir boucler notre dossier
effectivement à côté des drames humains
et de la menace sur l'intégrité
territoriale de la france le sport par
est un sujet léger mais s'il est
pourtant porteurs de symboles importants
ainsi ma question madame la ministre la
france va-t-elle appuyé la candidature
d'un pays qui attaquent la souveraineté
nationale ou soutenir pleinement et
uniquement mayotte pour accueillir les
jeux des îles de l'océan indien en 2027
la parole est à madame catherine colonna
ministre de l'europe et des affaires et
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs des députés mesdames les
députés youssoupha vous m'avez posé deux
questions en réalité la première porte
sur l'organisation des jeux des îles en
2027 et je vais être très clair si
mayotte souhaite se porter candidates
pour les accueillir
la diplomatie française sera mobilisé
pour défendre sa candidature auprès des
membres de la commission qui organise
ces jeux n'en doutez pas sur votre
deuxième question madame la députée je
peux vous assurer de la détermination de
la france à appuyer encore ses bonnes
relations avec les comores comme vous
l'avez souligné et ces relations sont
nécessaires pour lutter contre la
pression migratoire sur mayotte depuis
2010 9 depuis 2019 nous avons obtenu des
autorités comoriennes de pouvoir
procéder à une opération de reconduite
des clandestins par jour une opération
par jour plus de 20000 éloignement de
comoriens en situation irrégulière ont
ainsi été opérés en 2021 nous soutenons
également les opérations des forces
comoriennes à terre et en mer pour
empêcher le départ des barques depuis
l'île d'anjouan et j'ajoute madame n'a
débuté que depuis 2010 9 nous mettons en
oeuvre avec l'afd un important plan de
développement de 150 millions d'euros
pour lutter contre les causes profondes
d'immigration en particulier pour créer
des opportunités économiques pour les
jeunes aux comores ce plan met l'accent
notamment sur l'île d'anjouan d'où
partent comme vous le savez la plupart
des migrants je vous remercie
la parole est à monsieur nicolas thierry
madame la présidente
chers collègues cette question s'adresse
à madame la première ministre dix neuf
mille hectares de forêts partis en fumée
trente sept mille personnes déplacées
des milliers d'animaux sauvages en proie
aux flammes la gironde de brühl d'un ce
monstrueux combattu avec abnégation par
les pompiers dont je veux ici saluer le
courage
partout en france nous il faut qu'on
voit là l'effet du dérèglement
climatique qui nous accable ne voyons
pas ici la main du destin mais celle du
renoncement nos territoires souffre non
pas seulement de la canicule mais bel et
bien de l'inconséquence des gouvernants
qui n'ont cure de l'avenir écologique du
monde nous avons été trahis depuis trop
longtemps et par trop de dirigeants les
belles promesses ont succédé aux grands
discours à l'inaction a succédé à
l'immobilisme les forêts qui brûlent
laisse nos dernières illusions en sambre
alors même la première mal au mal madame
la première ministre vous avez le choix
soit rejoindre la cohorte honteuse de
ceux qui nous ont enfoncés dans la crise
écologique soit être la première
ministre qui affrontera avec lucidité le
nouveau régime climatique engendrée par
un capitalisme financier sans morale et
sans limite qui nous mène à notre
destruction le nouveau régime climatique
c'est la nature déboussoler les espèces
menacées et les plus précaires martyrisé
par l'injustice environnementale car si
les humains naissent libres et égaux en
droits partout les risques écologiques
frappe d'abord les plus démunis
s'adapter c'est essentiel mais ne
suffira pas il faut rompre avec la folie
productiviste qui préside depuis trop
longtemps on destine et environnemental
de notre pays hier votre gouvernement
n'a guère agi vérité pour cela condamné
mais je gage que la violence de la crise
écologique finira par convaincre les
plus réticents alors j'en finis ma
question sera simplement dans la
première ministre oui ou non allez vous
enfin agir pour le climat et la
biodiversité
oui ou non allez vous sortir notre
nation de sa dépendance aux énergies
fossiles est engagée désormais sans plus
attendre la seule politique viable celle
de la bifurcation écologique
merci la parole est à m e christophe
béchu ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires madame la présidente madame
la première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
thierry oui la première ministre va agir
elle va agir avec annie espagnol une
hache-- et moi-même dans le cadre du
pack qui a été déterminé par le
président de la république pour indiquer
qu'une feuille de route qui va valoir
pour la totalité des ministères de ce
gouvernement va définir les moyens
d'accélérer sur ces sujets pour changer
de braquet sur notre capacité sur ce
sujet à lutter contre le changement
climatique le président de la république
a eu l'occasion d'annoncer le 14 juillet
l'utilisation d'une partie de la
fiscalité sur les énergies fossiles pour
accélérer cette adaptation changement
climatique les dispositifs qui existent
pour être assemblés pour que nous
puissions concevoir une trajectoire
carbone pour notre pays qui permet aussi
de prendre à témoin l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens des efforts qui convient de
faire c'est très exactement le travail
que autour du secrétaire général à la
transition écologique monsieur peillon
nous sommes en train d'accomplir pour
rendre public dans les semaines qui
viennent à la fois cette feuille de
route et le plan d'adaptation au
changement climatique à compter de 2023
qui sera soumis et présenté à l'ensemble
des parlementaires
je vous remercie
la parole est à madame olga j'hibernais
merci
merci madame la présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de la
transition énergétique madame la
ministre à la hausse des prix de
l'énergie s'ajoute le risque de pénurie
il menace notre pays pour l'hiver
prochain nos énergéticiens français au
premier rang desquels edf nous alertent
la guerre en ukraine réduit
l'approvisionnement en gaz la baisse du
niveau des cours d'eau jalons une autre
production hydroélectrique et impacte
notre production nucléaire
nous subissons depuis de nombreux mois
la flambée des cours du pétrole les
indicateurs sont au rouge nous devons
trouver des solutions immédiates pour
protéger les plus modestes d'entre nous
avec les classes moyennes ils sont les
premiers touchés par cette crise le
projet de loi pouvoir d'achat offre dès
maintenant des réponses concrètes et
efficaces aux français pour qu'ils aient
les moyens de se déplacer puis de se
chauffer en hiver
l'hypothèse d'une coupure nette totale
des livraisons de gaz russe impose de
nous préparer au scénario du pire pour
faire face à cette pénurie qui nous
guette la sécurisation de notre
production et notre stockage d'énergie
est indispensable par ailleurs le 14
juillet dernier le président de la
république a annoncé un plan de sobriété
énergétique
il semble avoir été suivie d'un plan
d'un élan de rhésus responsabilité
les grandes enseignes de distribution
ont annoncé hier leur plan de sobriété
il va de soi que les premiers efforts
demandés s'adresse à ces grands groupes
industriels et commerciaux à nos
administrations aussi il dispose des
ressources nécessaires pour lutter
contre le gaspillage
au delà de cet exemple est essentielle
un plan de sobriété plus large devrait
être soumis aux français pour assurer le
bon passage de l'hiver il nous faut
structurer la cohésion nationale alors
madame la ministre ma question est la
suivante pouvez vous nous préciser les
grandes lignes et le calendrier de ce
plan porté par le gouvernement je vous
remercie
agnès pannier venait ministre de la
transition énergétique
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
giverny merci de poser en des termes
très clairs la situation dans lequel
nous sommes une situation de
responsabilité pour protéger le pouvoir
d'achat des français face à l'envolée
des prix de l'énergie et comme l'a
rappelé le ministre de l'économie tout à
l'heure nous avons bloqué les prix du
gaz bloquer les prix d'électricité cela
se poursuivra jusqu'à la fin de l'année
et nous prenons des mesures sur le
carburant mais nous sommes également
confrontés à une des crises énergétiques
les plus importantes depuis les années
70 en termes d'accès à l'énergie et dans
cette optique nous nous préparons nous
nous préparons par les mesures d'urgence
du projet de loi pouvoir d'achat que
vous connaissez bien nous augmentons nos
stockages stratégiques de gaz naturel
nous allons les remplir à 100% nous
mettons en place un terminal flottant
méthaniers pour pouvoir traiter plus de
volumes de gaz naturel liquéfié nous
sommes également en capacité de pouvoir
réquisitionner les centrales à gaz pour
mieux piloter notre système gazier notre
système électrique mais il faut aussi
agir en diminuant notre consommation
d'énergie notre consommation de
carburant notre consommation de gaz
notre consommation d'électricité
cela est parfait pour possible et c'est
dans cette optique que la première
ministre a lancé le 23 juin dernier je
le rappelle un plan de sobriété qui a
été immédiatement relayée auprès des
administrations car les ministères les
administrations doivent être exemplaires
auprès des grandes entreprises parce
qu'effectivement vous le dites elles ont
les moyens de s'organiser elle organise
sur tout le travail de millions de
français et donc dans les déplacements
dans l' usage des bâtiments elles sont
en pointe dans l'accueil d'un public de
clients elles sont en pointe pour
maîtriser les consommations énergétiques
nous allons également travailler avec le
logement le logement résidentiel tous
les gestionnaires de logements
résidentiels qu'ils soient sociaux ou
privés avec les activités du tourisme je
regarde mes collègues sur les boliviens
grégoire un clic et stanislas guérini
est notre objectif certes il % de
réduction
la parole est à monsieur laurent
alexandre
madame la présidente de ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'économie quel est l'avenir des fon de
riz en france mpf dans le jura fonderie
du poitou fonderie de bretagne et
maintenant la somme en aveyron
fermetures de sites licenciements
délocalisations
pourtant la fonderie est un maillon
indispensable de la souveraineté
industrielle du pays et pour la
bifurcation écologique
pourquoi abandonner la scène qui est la
seule fonderie en france à posséder un
bureau d'études cette usine travailler
principalement avec renault pour des
moteurs hybrides et électriques qui sont
vantés pourtant comme l'avenir cette
situation est inacceptable
elle résulte du choix de renault de
délocaliser cette activité en espagne et
en roumanie elle résulte du choix
politique du gouvernement d'accepter
cette délocalisation
l'état est en effet actionnaire de
renault
cette décision a entraîné le
licenciement de 3 133 salariés dans un
territoire le bassin minier de deux
cases ville déjà meurtrie par le déclin
industriel et la fermeture de sa
maternité nous avons appris hier que le
projet de reprise de l'activité de
s'emporter par l'industriel français
soutenu par les collectivités locales a
été retiré pourquoi parce que l'état
refuse de s'y engager c'est un abandon
lâche et cruel des populations
concernées des salariés mais aussi des
intérêts économiques du pays monsieur le
ministre monsieur le ministre comment
pouvez vous parler de
réindustrialisation de la france et
laissé délocaliser toutes les fonderie
la stratégie du gouvernement et de
renault est telle qu'il n'y ait plus une
seule fonderie en france vous engagez
vous intervenir auprès de renault pour
assurer des commandes pour permettre à
la reprise de l'assam
je vous remercie la parole et à monsieur
roland lescure ministre délégué chargé
de l'industrie
merci madame la présidente
mesdames messieurs les députés monsieur
le député laurent alexandre
je tiens à affirmer une fois de plus mon
refus de voir des entreprises privées
toucher des subventions publiques
c'est ce que vous disiez monsieur
laurent alexandre quand vous étiez
candidat du nouveau parti
anticapitaliste aux élections régionales
il ya quelques années alors je suis très
heureux de voir que vous reconnaissez
avec nous que oui l'état peut jouer un
rôle et il joue un rôle dans le soutien
de l'industrie française les jo ne
laisserai personne personne dire que
l'état n'a pas été présent depuis deux
mois dans le soutient depuis des mois
dans le soutien de l'assam
l'annoncé de la liquidation judiciaire
le ministre bruno le maire a reçu les
représentants des salariés pour leur
affirmer que nous les accompagnerons et
nous le faisons ma prédécesseure agnès
pannier rue nager annoncé une étude sur
le passé industriel pour le redynamiser
et nous la suivons rien que dans le
département ce qui a été voté par cette
même majorité monsieur le député
territoire d'industrie france relance
c'est plus de 40 millions plus de 20
millions pardon pour 40 entreprises et
en ce qui concerne nos projets nous
avons accompagné le repreneur en
refinançant son pge en payant les études
de faisabilité du projet et évidemment
nous étions prêts à financer l'opération
malheureusement et là je vous rejoins le
repreneur n'a pas souhaité poursuivre
cette opération pour deux raisons la
première c'est vrai du fait de commandes
insuffisantes du client historique et
d'une relation client-fournisseur il
faut le reconnaître et ça ne date pas
d'hier dégradée mais aussi et surtout du
fait de la conjoncture internationale de
la hausse des prix de l'énergie qui
rendait ce prodiguerait extrêmement
risqué sans doute trop risqué au risque
et ça vous ne souhaitiez pas de
fragiliser le repreneur lui même alors
aujourd'hui monsieur le député moi je
pense comme vous j'espère au salarié au
333 salariés que nous allons accompagner
j'ai déjà échangé avec mon collègue
olivier du soap pour les accompagneront
juste
si monsieur le ministre un
métier alexandre
quand vous dites accompagner les
salariés s'étaient peut-être tout
simplement permettre aux repreneurs de
pouvoir reprendre cette société avec
renault dont l'état est actionnaire et
quant à mon curriculum vitae je vous
invite à revoir vos fiches avec sophos
merci
la parole est à mme effet manuel tascher
de la pagerie
merci madame la présidente
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de la santé de la prévention
monsieur le ministre il est désormais
impossible de se rendre spontanément aux
urgences sur l'ensemble du territoire en
cause les fermetures partielles les
week-ends ou la nuit le manque de moyens
humains et matériels et une réelle
dégradation sans précédent de l'offre de
soins dans notre pays à celles ci
s'ajoutent les fermetures de lits
constante dans ma circonscription on
centre d'hospitalier d'arles 350 lits
ont été fermés en 20 ans dont 51 ans ces
trois derniers mois vous le disiez vous
même la situation est plus grave
aujourd'hui qu'elle ne l'était en 2019
quel aveu concernant les urgences nous
sommes au pied du mur tri des passions
mesure de verrouillage et de filtrage
ces dispositions ont pour conséquences
des dysfonctionnements menant à
l'épuisement des équipes soignantes ce
manque d'anticipation sap l'hôpital
public et le tiers monde dise comme
jamais nous réclamons un véritable plan
de recrutement des personnels la
titularisation des contractuels la
réintégration des soignants suspendu et
la revalorisation des indemnités de nuit
et de week end à arles il manque 25
infirmiers sur le centre hospitalier la
médecine libérale supplée à titre
associatif au personnel des urgences les
vendredis soirs de 20h à minuit alertée
par les personnels soignants l'hôpital
imbert est constamment en tension y
travaillent en mode dégradé les patients
restent des heures aux urgences avant
qu'ali ne le soient retrouvés vous le
savez le ségur de la santé a été
inefficace pour preuve les agents fut
l'hôpital au profit de l'appel de
l'intérim monsieur le ministre
qu'allez vous faire pour sauver nos
urgences qu'allez vous faire pour
l'attractivité de l'hôpital l' ouverture
des lits des oreilles de travail
cohérent pour la qualité de vie des
agents hospitaliers urgentiste merci
monsieur le ministre
je vous remercie
la parole est à monsieur françois braud
aux ministres de la santé de la
prévention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
madame la présidente mesdames messieurs
les députés monsieur le député tâcher de
la pagerie ma mission vous le savez en
tant que ministre chargé de la santé de
la prévention est de permettre à chaque
français d'être pris en charge de
manière adéquate lorsque cela est
nécessaire c'est cela répondre aux
besoins de santé de la population
je tout de suite coupé court à ce que
j'entends parfois oui chaque français
continuera bien entendu à être pris en
charge en urgence là où c'est le plus
utile pour lui je n'ai en aucun cas et
je ne préconise pas la fermeture des
services d'urgence nos services
d'urgence ont face à une tension inédite
qui n'est pas seulement lié aux
difficultés de l'hôpital mais un enjeu
systémique globale de l'organisation de
l'offre de soins c'est dans cette
perspective que nous travaillons c'est
dans cette perspective que je souhaite
mettre la réponse aux besoins de santé
au centre du futur dispositif plutôt que
la réponse de l'offre de soins j'avais à
la demande de ma prédécesseure madame
bourguignon réaliser une mission flash
qui a permis d'aboutir à quarante et une
proposition pour améliorer le
fonctionnement de l'hôpital dès cet été
la première ministre a fait le choix de
retenir ses propositions pour la période
estivale et de les évaluer pendant l'été
à la fin de l'année il ne vous aura pas
échappé d'ailleurs que dans ses
propositions il y à la titularisation
des personnels en attente et c'était
déjà possible à l'issue du ségur je
prendrai pour exemple l'hôpital de pau
qui vient d'annoncer de titulariser 200
personnes il y avait également le
renforcement de l'indemnité de nuit
nous avons veillé à proposer des
solutions concrètes pour garantir un
accès aux soins aux français durant cet
été les propositions déclinées sont dans
trois axes la responsabilité de chacun
en appelant son médecin traitant ou en
appelant le 15 avant de se déplacer aux
urgences pour trouver une meilleure
solution la disponibilité des
professionnels avec des mesures sur
l'attractivité pour la première fois la
reconnaissance justement de la
pénibilité la nuit ainsi qu'une
meilleure coordination entre la ville et
l'hôpital
les mesures mises en oeuvre et pour
lesquelles j'ai signé une instruction
aux ars vise à mieux organiser les
services je vous remercie monsieur
tâcher de la pagerie et bien écoutez je
ne suis absolument pas étonné par cette
réponse que je qualifierais de piteuses
monsieur le ministre j'ai donc rentré à
arles pour expliquer au personnel
hospitalier qui continuent de se crever
à la tâche sans aucune réponse de son
ministère tutélaire je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre
la parole est à monsieur réal pandarie
merci aux neuf la présidente
ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères madame la ministre mes chers
collègues la situation dramatique
des incendies détourne temporairement
notre attention et celle de nos
concitoyens de la situation aux
frontières de l'europe
notre population reste inquiète sur
l'évolution du franc ils craignent un
ses conséquences immédiates tant en
matière de pouvoir d'achat que de
pressions sur les prix alimentaires et
énergétiques
ces pressions risque de sa serbe
exacerbée lors de l'hiver prochain bien
sûr nous faisons des efforts importants
pour sécuriser nos approvisionnements
mais ce livre est là l'herbe verte et e
sur d'éventuels délestages et coupures
d'électricité lors du prochain hiver
par ailleurs certains faits divers
pourrait finir par se faire questionner
les français sur l'acceptation de ces
sanctions face à cela comment aider les
ukrainiens et l'ukraine sans favoriser
l' escalade des conflits comment l'union
européenne garantis
l'effectivité des sanctions à l'encontre
de ceux qui mènent la guerre sans
pénaliser nos concitoyens
depuis l'agression russe et le premier
débat devant la représentation nationale
début mars en six mois la situation a
considérablement évolué elle s'est
aggravée dès lors le groupe horizon et
apparentés sollicite un nouveau débat
devant la représentation nationale sur
la situation en ukraine et ses
conséquences géostratégiques à l'endroit
de l'europe et du quotidien des français
merci
je vous remercie la parole est à mme
adams rôle d'un ministre de l'europe et
des affaires étrangères
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
alfandari je vous remercie de votre
question car le parler de rappeler que
les sanctions étaient indispensables
indispensable en raison de l'agression
dont la russie s'est rendu coupable et
afin de peser sur son effort de guerre
ces sanctions de touche plusieurs
domaines économiques et bancaires
politique financier sectorielle mais si
le domaine de l'information
notre objectif monsieur débuté et claire
asphyxier les capacités de financement
du régime par l'immobilisation de plus
de la moitié des avoirs de la banque
centrale de russie et par la limitation
de sa rente énergétique
visé directement les individus qui
contribue à l'effort de guerre
responsables politiques militaires
oligarques et en particulier par le gel
de leurs avoirs
limiter la capacité de nuisance de la
russie en la privant d'accès aux
technologies occidentales dans certains
secteurs stratégiques comme
l'aéronautique ou la défense par exemple
empêcher enfin la propagande russe en
suspendant comme nous l'avons fait les
chaîne russia today et spoutnik hier
encore à bruxelles nous avons décidé
avec mes collègues européens de
renforcer ses mesures en mettant en
place un embargo sur l'or qui privera la
russie de plusieurs milliards d'euros de
recettes par an et en renforçant des
sanctions individuelles et puisque vous
m'offrez l'occasion monsieur le député
je veux rappeler que ce ne sont pas les
sanctions qui crée des tensions sur les
marchés de l'énergie c'est d'ailleurs
choisi est mené par la russie en ukraine
ce ne sont pas les sanctions qui
accroissent l'insécurité alimentaire
dans le monde c'est la guerre choisie
est menée par la russie en ukraine la
russie qui bombardent les
infrastructures céréalière de l'ukraine
qui bloque ses ports et qui parfois vol
ses récoltes voilà la réalité merci
monsieur le député vous remercie un
ministre
la parole est à monsieur thibault bazin
merci madame la présidente madame un
premier ministre l'inflation rogne le
pouvoir d'achat des français lorsque
nous vous proposons des mesures pour
vraiment baisser les taxes sur les
carburants vous nous brandissent et la
dette abyssale de notre pays pourtant
bien caché pendant les campagnes
électorales que nous venons de traverser
or pour le financement les républicains
ne cesse de vous inviter à faire enfin
des réformes structurelles par exemple
lutter contre les fraudes la fraude
sociale coûterait entre 14 et 45
milliards d'euros par an une des mesures
que nous vous avons déjà proposé et
l'instauration de carte vitale
biométrique
ce sont des cartes dont la puce contient
un paramètres relatifs à des
caractéristiques physiques de l'assuré
comme ses empreintes digitales par
exemple c'est un système qui assure une
très grande fiabilité contre les risques
de fraude il n'y aurait plus de près de
cartes possibles et les cartes volées ne
pourrait plus être utilisé en effet
comment expliquer à nos concitoyens
15,8 à 2 millions de cartes vitale
circulent en trop dans l'hexagone
comment admettre qu'une tierce personne
utilise à l'hôpital ou chez un
professionnel de santé une carte qui
n'est pas la sienne
comment admettre qu'en cas de vol ou de
perte la puce met tant de temps à être
désactivée quand les le sénat l'a voté
en 2019 mais vous l'avez ensuite rejetée
à l'assemblée nationale au prétexte
qu'une expérimentation était déjà menée
dans quelques départements avec une
carte vitale dématérialisée et non
biométrique quel mauvais prétextes votre
carte vitale dématérialisée n'empêchera
pas la fraude madame la première
ministre qu'attendez vous pour
généraliser désormais la carte vitale
biométrique que nous vous proposons
je vous remercie
la parole est à monsieur françois braud
de ministre de la santé de la prévention
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
bazin la sécurité sociale est un
patrimoine très précieux pour les
français et j'en suis le garant nous
devons donc protéger ce patrimoine et
s'assurer que les prestations sont
versées à bon droit que les cotisations
et contributions sociales sont
recouvrées de manière exhaustive
ma position est celle du gouvernement
est très claire aucune complaisance à
l'égard de ceux qui fraudent comme
l'indiqué la première ministre lors de
sa déclaration de politique générale
pour autant nous devons avoir une
approche rationnelle de ce sujet à
travers une évaluation objective du
manque à gagner et l'adoption de mesures
adaptées
[Musique]
le gouvernement vous l'avais dit à
déployer le dispositif de cartes
électroniques cartes vitale sécurisé
dématérialisée
permettant l'authentification la
signature des assurés pour les
différents actes il convient là aussi de
l'évaluer mais monsieur le député bazin
vous souhaitez le déploiement de carte
vitale biométrique
cette question mérite de travailler car
il existe plusieurs dispositifs et qu'il
nous faut paillard d'ailleurs en évaluer
les conditions d'efficacité de
faisabilité en lien avec les
professionnels je connais votre
engagement et celui du groupe l'est
républicain en faveur de la lutte contre
la fraude sociale
comme vous le savez le gouvernement est
à l'écouté des idées constructives pour
faire avancer notre pays de façon
transparente izan
ainsi à la demande de la première
ministre le gouvernement soutiendra une
mission parlementaire afin de suivre le
déploiement en cours de la nouvelle
carte vitale sans aucun tabou et sans
préjugés afin d'en évaluer
la pertinence et les évolutions
possibles je vous remercie
je vous remercie monsieur bazin merci
monsieur le ministre votre réponse est
décevante encore une mission les
français attendent plus d'efficacité
l'évaluation est connue les fraudes
liées aux cartes vitales sont estimés à
près de 5,4 milliards la carte vitale
biométrique coûte 400 millions cela
pourrait rapporter 5 milliards par an
vous manquez vraiment de volonté on vous
attend pour mieux lutter contre les
fraudes
je vous remercie
la parole est à madame sonia bourreau à
madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers collègues je voudrais tout d'abord
avoir une pensée au nom du groupe gdr
pour celles et ceux qui combattent les
incendies ravageurs sur notre territoire
et la population tente et privé par ce
drame ma question s'adresse au ministre
de l'éducation nationale dans un mois en
outre-mer et un mois et demi en
métropole c'est la rentrée scolaire ce
qui devrait être un moment important
pour notre république pour nos enfants
pour leur famille devient un facteur
d'angoissé pour tout le monde postes non
pourvus classes surchargées
h insuffisant médecine scolaire
inexistante le constat partagé est
inquiétant à la demande de l'ensemble
des députés du département vous êtes
venu vendredi en seine saint denis où
nous vous avons fait part de l'état
alarmant de notre école malgré votre
écoute vous ne vous n'avait annoncé
aucune mesure concrète
monsieur le ministre la réponse ne peut
être nous ferons avec les moyens du bord
nous n'accepterons pas ce continuel
mépris plus longtemps les équipes
pédagogiques les enfants et les familles
sont épuisés par plusieurs années de
fonctionnement dégradé la réponse du
président de la république proposant
l'autonomie des établissements et la
création d'une école à la carte
entérinant les inégalités est à l'opposé
de ce dont nos enfants ont besoin
nos propositions sont sur la table un
recrutement à bac + 3 avec l'ouverture
d'un concours exceptionnel de suite un
appel des candidats admis sur liste
complémentaire ou admissibles
l'ouverture de concours spéciaux dans
les académies déficitaire la
reconduction et la titularisation des
contractuels
le recrutement d aes h à eu des cpe en
nombre médecine scolaire assistante
sociale l'école est en état d'urgence
alors monsieur le ministre après le
constat allez vous reprendre nos
propositions celle des professeurs et
des familles
vous remercie la parole et me fait à
monsieur pape ndiaye ministre de
l'éducation de la formation
professionnelle
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
buchhart le ministère prépare depuis
plusieurs mois très activement la
rentrée scolaire c'est vrai du côté de
la situation sanitaire avec la diffusion
la semaine dernière d'un nouveau
protocole sanitaire c'est vrai également
du côté du recrutement des enseignants
votre département de la seine saint
denis plus largement l'académie de
créteil sont en effet particulièrement
confrontés à des difficultés de
recrutement d'ailleurs j'ai pu présenter
à vous même et à vos collègues députés
lors de ma visite à bobigny vendredi
dernier une série de mesures pour
compenser la baisse de recrutement du
concours de professeurs des écoles que
nous avons constaté cette année des
enseignants sous contrat ont été
recrutés pour garantir un bon recrues à
un bon déroulement de la rentrée 2022
aux côtés des enseignants titulaires et
notre objectif c'est de disposer d'un
vivier d'enseignants remplaçants
suffisant pour l'ensemble de l'année
scolaire de manière plus structurelle
conformément aux engagements du
président de la république et de la
première ministre le ministère engagera
dès la rentrée une concertation pour
renforcer l'attractivité des métiers
d'enseignants pour l'académie de créteil
en particulier nous réfléchissons aux
moyens de fidéliser les contractuels qui
ont été recrutés afin de bien les formes
et de leur permettre d'exercer leur
métier dans de bonnes conditions et de
pouvoir passer les concours enseignants
selon des modalités que nous aurons à
travailler à partir de la rentrée
j'ai eu le plaisir d'échanger avec vous
la semaine dernière croyez bien
que les questions et les problèmes qui
sont ceux de la seine saint denis sont
aussi les miens
je vous remercie madame bourgeois
merci merci monsieur le ministre les
enjeux sont importants et comme vous
nous l'avez proposé nous nous reverrons
en septembre pour faire le point merci
je vous remercie la parole est à madame
christine décote merci madame la
présidente ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre des transports
monsieur le ministre la canicule que
nous subissons et qui coïncide avec les
départs en vacances affecte durement les
voyageurs et les réseaux de transport en
effet les conditions de voyage
deviennent particulièrement compliqué
pour nombre de voyageurs en particulier
les plus fragiles enfants et personnes
âgées nous l'avons encore vu hier dans
plusieurs trains y compris du quotidien
de plus les infrastructures elle même
souffre de la chaleur excessive en
particulier les routes et les voies
ferrées ce qui engendre des
perturbations importantes
nous le savons ces épisodes de chaleur
sont amenés à se reproduire et à
s'intensifier
il va nous falloir adapter très vite
notre réseau à ces enjeux par ailleurs
en plus de la chaleur les français
souffrent des conséquences sur leur
pouvoir d'achat de la situation
internationale en particulier concernant
le prix des carburants en cette période
estivale le budget des familles risquent
donc d'être particulièrement affectée
par ces augmentations au risque de
remettre en cause une partie de leurs
vacances monsieur le ministre ma
question est donc simple face à ces
enjeux que prévoyez-vous pour assurer
aux français qu'ils pourront se déplacer
sereinement cet été merci
merci
parole est à monsieur clément bonne
ministre délégué aux transports
merci madame la présidente n'amuse et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
christine des codes vous assistez à
juste raison sur un certain nombre
d'enjeux dans un contexte assez
exceptionnel cet été au moment des
grandes vacances dans le secteur des
transports exceptionnels parce que nous
connaissons c'est à certains égards une
bonne nouvelle une reprise très forte de
l'activité du tourisme et des transports
dans le secteur ferroviaire dans le
secteur aérien qui pose aussi des
problèmes de réorganisation de suite un
certain nombre d'opérateurs nous l'avons
subi malheureusement un contexte
exceptionnel par les très fortes
chaleurs que nous connaissons encore en
ce moment même et un contexte
exceptionnel est difficile pour le
pouvoir d'achat sur tous ces sujets le
gouvernement est extrêmement mobilisés
dans le domaine des transports avec
christophe béchu nous le sommes tout
particulièrement c'est le cas sur la
question du pouvoir d'achat vous le
discuter dans cette assemblée cette
scène cette semaine même avec deux
textes très important
nous le savons pour les déplacements du
quotidien comme pour les vacances 80 %
des trajets se font encore par la route
et donc il est normal d'accompagner dans
une période d'urgence les françaises et
les français qui roulent le plus en
particulier par des mesures que nous
prolongeons sur le carburant tout en
réfléchissant à des dispositifs plus
pérenne nous le faisons aussi je me suis
engagé en discutant avec les sociétés
d'autoroutes il y eut un premier geste
nous continuerons en vue des prochains
mois de la rentrée et des mois qui
suivent et vous le faites ici dans les
travaux parlementaires en réfléchissant
à d'autres mesures je salue notamment
vos travaux ceux du président ou les i
sur l'encouragement l'utilisation des
transports publics nous le faisons face
aux fortes chaleurs je veux saluer la
mobilisation des grands opérateurs du
secteur ferroviaire du secteur aérien
qui distribuent de l'eau qui dispense
des conseils aux voyageurs nous
accélérons et puis je le dis aussi vous
l'avez rappelé il y a eu des problèmes
des difficultés malgré tout certaines
images choquantes hier sur notre réseau
francilien du rer b j'ai contacté bien
sûr les opérateurs qui ont présenté
leurs excuses je crois que c'était
nécessaire hier nous en tirons les
leçons pour que cela ne se reproduise
pas et puis nous devons accélérer
évidemment sur le long terme sur la
transition écologique la première
ministre l'a rappelé devant votre
assemblée la colonne vertébrale de la
transformation et du verdissement notre
mode de transport c'est le ferroviaire
nous investirons encore davantage
que nous ayons un réseau et les
transports de meilleure qualité ministre
madame
donc la parole est à madame marie
charlotte garin
madame la présidente madame la première
ministre chers collègues lors d'une
séance au sénat en avril 2013 madame
cayeux avait qualifié le mariage pour
tous et l'adoption ouverte aux couples
de même sexe de réforme de caprices et
de dessins qui va contre la nature
interrogé la semaine dernière elle a
confirmé ses propos elle a même dit elle
beaucoup d'amis parmi ces gens là
ces gens là ces gens là
nombreux sont les enfants qui
grandissent avec ce stigmate celui de la
différence celui de la norme qui étouffe
celui du secret celui du silence celui
du placard celui de la discrimination
parfois quotidienne
rarement assumer et souvent insidieuse
ce sont ses enfants qui une fois adultes
sont deux à trois fois plus exposés aux
violences psychologiques physiques
sexuelles ou verbales ce sont ces mêmes
enfants qui seront plus exposés aux
dépressions ou aux tentatives de suicide
cet impact sur la santé mentale des
discriminations nous oblige à nommer les
propos de madame cayeux pour ce qu'ils
sont des propos homophobes
ça n'est pas une maladresse ou une
erreur une fois dit sitôt excusé c'est
un délit
on a eu ce monsieur darmanin où monsieur
le corps nu soutien de la manif pour
tous on à monsieur béchu qui avait fait
interdire des affiches de prévention
contre le vih sous prétexte qu'elles
montraient ciel des couples de même sexe
aux abords des écoles et maintenant
madame cayeux
ça n'est pas un hasard c'est un choix
politique
madame la première ministre franchement
comment pouvez-vous nommer dans votre
gouvernement ces gens là
la parole est un monsieur olivier derand
ministre chargé du renouveau
démocratique et porte parole du
gouvernement
madame madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
la députée pour tout vous dire il ya dix
ans j'étais dans cet hémicycle à
quelques mètres de votre place puisque
j'étais dans une majorité qui
travaillait avec les écologistes et les
socialistes et j'ai fait partie d'une
majorité à l'époque qui a bataillé jour
et nuit pendant plusieurs semaines pour
permettre de voter la loi sur le mariage
pour tous et l'adoption par les couples
de même sexe
j'en garde un souvenir ému
ému parce que nous avons fait progresser
la société à travers ce texte de loi je
regarde aussi un souvenir ému par ce que
d'autres banques sur d'autres
parlementaires qui avaient d'autres
conviction que les nôtres à l'époque
avait pu avoir des mots qui pouvaient
blesser des mots qui pouvait faire mal
et qui ont pu batailler acquis de nous
dire nous prédire l'effondrement la
civilisation si les homosexuels
pouvaient se marier acquis prédire le
malaise et le mal-être pour les enfants
de venir s'ils étaient adoptés par des
familles homosexuelles nous ont fait
face avec conviction conviction parce
que nous savions que nous avions raison
est que ce que nous portions s'était
finalement tout simplement le droit à
l'indifférence les opposants au mariage
pour tous il était plutôt sur ses bancs
là et parfois ils étaient d'ailleurs
virulent certains sont toujours là
écoutez la réponse au député aujourd'hui
avec dix ans de recul disons bonheur
pour des milliers de familles pour des
milliers d'enfants je pense que les
positions des députés qui à l'époque
étaient opposés ont bien évolué parce
que face au bonheur on peut que
constater qu'on avait tort de se vouloir
s'y opposer
alors oui certains mots peuvent faire
mal certains mots peuvent blesser
peuvent heurter nous devons nous garder
les prononcer voire plus encore nous
devons nous garder de les penser mais
sur ces bancs madame la députée sur le
banc du gouvernement sur le banc des
députés de la majorité sur les bancs
d'ailleurs de votre groupe delane ups de
gauche et même d'ailleurs sur la plupart
des bornes cet hémicycle y compris à
droite désormais nous avons une chose en
commun la volonté farouche de faire
évoluer notre société pour qu'elle
reflète toute sa diversité toute sa
richesse tout ce qu'elle peut accueillir
deux baux qui pourrait encore
aujourd'hui nier qu'il ya bien des
manières d'aimer qu'aucune n'est
supérieur à l'autre il n'y a pas de ces
gens là il ya des femmes et des hommes
qui ne demandent rien d'autre qu'aux
secouristes et respecter les wc vivre
merci monsieur le ministre
madame gare un
jeu je note monsieur le ministre que
vous n'avez pas répondu à la question et
moi je veux m'adresser aux personnes qui
regardent et notamment aux enfants qui
ont survécu et je leur dit soyez fiers
parce que nous défendrons vos droits
la parole est à monsieur julien aux
bulls
merci madame la présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur le ministre ce
n'est plus un sentiment ce n'est plus un
fantasme
n'en déplaise à votre collègue monsieur
eric dupond moretti
la france est devenue un coup gorge à
angers amiens metz loriol sur drôme et
sérignan six personnes ont été attaqués
au couteau égorgé massacrés lors du
week-end du 14 juillet dans ma
circonscription lors d'un affrontement
entre bandes rivales de sens et de
parents deux individus ont été
poignardés l'un a été envoyé à l'hôpital
cochin pour un poumon perforé monsieur
le ministre il faut regarder les
chiffres terrifiants de votre bilan une
agression gratuite toutes les 44
secondes 120 attaques au couteau par
jour plus de 12% d'agressions physiques
en 2021 c'est votre bilan
monsieur le ministre il faut aussi
regarder la réalité en face cette
violence inouïe cette violence sauvage
et gratuite est alimenté par une
immigration de masse que vous soutenez
inlassablement
en effet les auteurs
les auteurs monsieur le ministre ont
quasiment tous les mêmes profils à
angers c'est un réfugié politique
soudanais qui a assassiné trois jeunes
rugbymans âgés de 16 à 20 ans
amiens sdf a été poignardé à mort par un
tunisien en situation irrégulière
combien de drames faudra-t-il pour agir
combien de français battu à mort combien
de jeunes poignardé combien de femmes
violées combien de policiers agressés
pour que votre gouvernement se réveille
monsieur le ministre il ya urgence a
renvoyé tout ce qui représente une
menace pour notre peuple monsieur le
ministre allez vous enfin traiter les
criminels étrangers comme nos ennemis
monsieur le ministre
quand allez vous enfin arrêter cette
immigration sauvage et garantir à tous
les français
le droid la parole est un monsieur eric
dupond-moretti mme garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente mesdames messieurs
les députés monsieur le député odoul
décidément ça n'est ni l'abi ni la
cravate qu'il faut le moine on veut
retrouve on vous retrouve tel que vous
êtes la réalité voyez-vous la réalité
voyez-vous la réalité voyez vous je
parviendrai à vous répondre ne vous en
déplaise c'est quand même l'objet des
questions que vous me posez c'est que
vous présenter aux français des
solutions clés en main vous avez non pas
la baguette magique mais la matraque
magique et nous savons que si par
malheur demain vous étiez au pouvoir on
vivre est au pays des bisounours plus un
crime plus une infraction vous sauriez
tout faire mais je vais vous dire
monsieur redoules nous n'avons ni gérald
darmanin nîmois de leçon à recevoir de
vous parce que quand nous avons augmenté
le nombre de forces de l'ordre de 10
mille vos amis du front national n'était
pas là pour voter non madame le pen
quand nous avons augmenté de 700 les
magistrats de ce pays vous n'étiez pas
là
lorsque nous avons mis en place le plan
des 15000 places de prisons net vous
n'étiez pas là et mieux encore vos amis
n'ont jamais prêté de terrain pour que
nous puissions construire les prisons ça
suffit et en matière de prévention le
code de justice pénale des mineurs vous
ne l'avez pas voter mesdames et
messieurs du rassemblement national une
dernière chose vous mentez en permanence
sur la justice laxiste
les juges de 2021 sentent une virgule
cinq fois plus sévère que les juges de
2000 et vous mentez encore à nos
compatriotes
lorsque vous dites que les peines ne
sont pas exécutées voilà la réalité
voilà vous m'en sors je me suis réputé
ono le maire soumet ses ministres
[Applaudissements]
la parole
la parole est père madame josy poeyto
merci madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
madame la secrétaire d'état chargée de
la jeunesse et du service national
universel
l'articulation à venir du service
national universel lui et ses nus
dépendent désormais du ministère de
l'éducation nationale et du ministère
des armées avec l' enthousiasme qui vous
caractérise madame la secrétaire d'état
vous incarnerez une nouvelle fois dans
ce gouvernement ce s est venu mais cette
fois en tant que secrétaire d'état
chargée de la jeunesse et du service
national universel
finalement cette configuration illustre
bien l'évolution de la mise en oeuvre
d'une ceni dont l'origine dans la
présidente législature avait été portée
par le ministère des armées avant de
passer sous la tutelle de l'éducation
nationale cette façon de travailler en
transversalité entre deux ministères est
intéressante à plus d'un titre elle
permet à la fois de déployer avec
davantage de cohérence des leviers
d'insertion sociale et professionnelle
et de renouer avec la citoyenneté avec
ce qui fait natio pour reconstruire un
mieux vivre ensemble cependant à ce
stade d'une nouvelle organisation qui se
met en place d'une nouvelle ambition est
alors que je suis interrogé sur la
montée en puissance du s est nu peu
d'informations ont été communiquées à ce
sujet madame la secrétaire d'état
pouvez-vous partager aujourd'hui avec la
représentation nationale les éléments de
nature à illustrer plus particulièrement
le rôle du ministère des armées dans la
trajectoire du s est tenue dans les
années qui viennent je vous remercie
la parole est à madame sarah lee
secrétaire d'état chargée de la jeunesse
et du service national universel
merci beaucoup madame la présidente
mesdames messieurs les députés madame la
députée prieto je vous remercie de poser
cette question parce qu'elle me permet
également de saluer les quarante mille
jeunes qui ont servi et qui ont vécu
cette expérience absolument unique
quarante mille jeunes qui ont fait
nation accompagné de plusieurs milliers
d'encadrants madame la députée et qui
ont vécu depuis 2019 ont rejoint cette
grande communauté des volontaires du
service national vers celle pour
atteindre 70 mille jeunes madame la
députée les corps en uniforme
aujourd'hui participe déjà au service
national universel en encadrant bien sûr
un tiers des encadrants viennent soit
des réserves des réservistes soit des
retraités de nos armées il participe au
séjour de cohésion il participe
également à la journée défense et
mémoire ils accueillent nos jeunes lors
des missions d'intérêt général dans la
phase deux avec des préparations
militaires mais également en réalité
avec des missions mémorielle ça vient
compléter l'engagement du monde
associatif ça vient compléter
l'engagement du monde de l'éducation
populaire et de l'éducation nationale et
c'est pour cela que avoir cette double
tutelle être aux côtés du ministre des
armées sébastien lecornu être aux côtés
du ministre de l'éducation nationale et
de la jeunesse pap ndiaye est une chance
pour nos jeunes est ce parce que plus
que jamais madame la députée nous
réunissons l'excellence lé excellence
française autour de nos jeunes c'est
notre priorité est évidemment cette
priorité elle se déploiera pour engager
et accroître la culture de l'engagement
de l'engagement civique et citoyen dont
notre jeunesse a tant besoin oui nous
avons besoin de cohésion nationale oui
nous avons besoin de mixité sociale oui
nous avons besoin d'égalité des chances
et il se trouve que ces trois excellence
le permettent madame la députée pour
répondre très explicitement à votre
question l'école l'armée au delà des
valeurs partagées au delà du mérite
qu'il permet de transmettre au delà des
valeurs de travail d'efforts de
collectif
aujourd'hui nous sommes en train de
faire avec le ministre des armées et le
ministre l'éducation nationale
l'inventaire l'état des lieux des outils
et des moyens
merci beaucoup
la parole est un monsieur johnny ajar
merci madame la présidente pour mesdames
et messieurs les ministres et aux
collègues ma question s'adresse à la
première ministre la situation en
matière d'insécurité en martinique est
extrêmement grave depuis six mois c'est
plus de 2 meur par arme à feu et par
mois et plus d'une quarantaine de
tentative d'homicide avec une
recrudescence de l'utilisation d'armes
de guerre à arriver sur nos territoires
en même temps que la drogue d'ailleurs
la martinique est aussi une porte
d'entrée de la drogue vers la france et
le continent européen cette insécurité
grandissante est la conséquence d'un
climat social extrêmement tendu du fait
notamment de la cherté structurel est
organisée de la vie dans le territoire
d'outre-mer à ce sujet votre projet de
loi sur le pouvoir d'achat est
totalement déconnectée de la réalité à
l'insécurité sociale s'ajoute
l'insécurité physique c'est
insupportable humainement car la vie de
personnes est en danger au quotidien la
sécurité est une prérogative régalienne
de l'état
la martinique vous invite donc à gio
concrètement alors que les homicides
dans les régions dit dit outre-mer bat
des records en france les moyens alloués
à ces territoires sont très largement
insuffisants au regard des besoins réels
l'égalité des droits humains doit être
un principe de fonctionnement
républicain dans l'urgence des moyens
humains logistiques supplémentaires sont
extrêmement importants déployés par
l'état en martinique au niveau local à
l'initiative de serge letchimy les
forces vives travaille sur des
propositions concrètes qui vous seront
remises d'ici quelques semaines il
s'agit d'agir en co construction de
manière réfléchie et pragmatique
la vision globale et réel est de mise il
s'agit de la traduit au travers de
moyens d'action et de protection de le
code de nos quartiers de nos familles
les plus vulnérables avec une
coordination police justice urgente à
renforcer
d'autre part une visite d'urgence avec
une délégation interministérielle
représentatif de l'importance que vous
accordez aux martiniquais s'impose seul
vous acte répondront de votre niveau
d'engagement et de volonté
ainsi quelles mesures fortes et
concrètes comptez-vous mettre en place
afin d'assurer particulièrement la
protection et la tranquillité des
martiniquais je vous remercie
la parole et à monsieur gérald darmanin
ministre de l'intérieur et des outre mer
la présidente mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député ailleurs vous
avez parfaitement raison il faut mettre
des noms sur les choses si depuis
plusieurs semaines plusieurs mois il y a
beaucoup d'armes à feu qui circulent et
s'il ya beaucoup de miss id c'est parce
que hein ça tombe de trafiquants de
drogue essaye vous le savez vous l'avais
dit à demi mots mais je sais que vous
connaissez cette difficulté essaye de
mettre la martinique comme une plaque
tournante de la drogue entre l'amérique
latine et l'amérique du sud et l'europe
et essayent d'imposer sa loi contre
celle de la république il faut dire que
la république se défend depuis plusieurs
semaines plusieurs mois sous l'effet
notamment de la police nationale la
gendarmerie que je remercie avait saisie
record de drogue que jamais la
martinique d'inconnus des saisies
d'armes très importante 93% ne serait-ce
que ce mois ci qui est à la fois le
travail des services mais aussi le
révélateur d'une délinquance très
importante et dont les règlements de
compte les homicides ont un lien
quasiment systématique avec ce trafic de
drogue j'ai donc décidé d'abord le
ministre d outre-mer sous l'autorité de
l'après midi se rendent aujourd'hui et
demain en martinique et en guadeloupe
pour notamment posé un diagnostic de
sécurité avec des locaux je me rendrai à
la fin de l'été avec lui peut-être avec
monsieur le garde des sceaux s'il le
souhaite puisque j'ai entendu votre
demande et je soulignerai d'abord les
moyens très importants que l'état va
mettre à disposition d'un martinique
pour lutter contre ce fléau d'abord la
création d'une antenne raid qui va
s'installer en arctique dans l'es17
était une augmentation très importante
des effectifs de police et un lien tout
particulier avec l'autorité judiciaire
il manque aussi beaucoup de caméras de
vidéoprotection vous le savez en
martinique nous allons donc augmenté de
façon conséquente des moyens et j'allais
dire monsieur le député puisque vous
aidé dans ce combat qu'il faut que
toutes les formations politiques
soutiennent nos policiers parce qu'ils
sont très blessé lorsqu'il entendre des
mots blessants et qu'on leur demande
après d'agir
je vous remercie
on peut le dépôt la parole est à mme
d'amours aurélie trouvé
c'est madame la présidente
colossal c'est ainsi que challenge
qualifie les résultats des 500 plus
grandes fortunes françaises en 2022 plus
de mille milliards d'euros de patrimoine
plus 300 % en douze ans retenait ce
chiffre plus 300 % parce que pendant ses
douze années de combien augmenter le
smic le savez vous et bien de 22
malheureux % et le smic réel y compris
l'inflation 0%
colossal c'est ainsi qu'on peut
qualifier l'explosion des inégalités les
plus riches toujours plus riches les
pauvres toujours plus pauvres 400000
pauvres supplémentaires pendant le
dernier quinquennat et c'est votre
responsabilité votre bilan vous avez
c'est l'économie de plus d'un milliard
sur le dos des chômeurs en rabotant
l'assurance chômage 1 milliards sur le
dos des mal logés en rabotant les apl et
en même temps lisf supprimer la flat tax
et des tombereaux de subventions aux
profiteurs et de cadeaux fiscaux
colossal c'est aussi le choc qui
s'annonce lorsque les hausses de prix
seront à leur paroxysme dans quelques
mois l'inflation est à 5% c'est déjà
insupportable pour la plupart des
français mais le pire est à venir
l'électricité et le gaz devrait
augmenter de 50% l'hiver prochain que
faites-vous face à cela quoi qu'il
arrive quoi qu'il en coûte vous restez
le gouvernement des riches vous refusez
vous refusez de mettre à contribution
les ultra riches et les grands
actionnaires alors même que l'inflation
fait exploser les profits des géants des
transports ou de l'énergie face à cela
le royaume uni lui prépare une taxe
exceptionnelle de 25 % sur les profits
pétroliers et gaziers l'italie 25% sur
l'énergie même chose en espagne y
compris sur les banques ce qui est
colossal c'est l'injustice de votre
politique
combien de temps encore monsieur le
ministre vous nous dites que vous
comptez sur les entreprises dans les
mois à venir vous nous dites ça depuis
cinq ans je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est un
monsieur bruno le maire ministre de
l'économie des finances de la
souveraineté industrielle numérique
madame le président de l'oms et
messieurs les députés d'un député
trouvez un mensonge répété mille fois ne
fera jamais une vérité
la vérité madame panneaux c'est que
notre politique comme vient de
l'indiquer récemment le rapport sur la
pauvreté nous a permis en pleine crise
économique en pleine flambée de
l'inflation de contenir l'augmentation
la pauvreté en france alors qu'elle a
augmenté dans les autres pays européens
la vérité c'est que notre politique
économique de protection des plus
faibles a permis de protéger le pouvoir
d'achat des français en 2021 alors même
que nous étions confrontés à des
difficultés économiques majeures
la difficulté c'est que nous avons
revalorisé l'intégralité des prestations
sociales et que nous vous proposons à
nouveau de revaloriser les prestations
sociales et que nous n'avons jamais
laissé tomber les plus faibles dans
notre pays la vérité 20 panneaux c'est
que la meilleure solution pour lutter
contre la pauvreté les inégalités c'est
d'aller vers le plein emploi et c'est
exactement ce que cette majorité va
réussir à faire mais grâce à vous madame
pado
j'ai compris j'ai compris même trouvé
qu'elle était la philosophie politique
de votre famille politique il n'y a pas
de difficultés économiques auxquelles
une taxe de puisse apporter une solution
un problème une taxe une difficulté un
prélèvement obligatoire une crise
économique un impôt supplémentaire
ça fait 30 ans qu'on essaye cela trente
ans que ça conduit au chômage 30 ans a
attendu à l'appauvrissement des français
30 ans que ça désespère et des classes
moyennes trop ton que ça désespérer tous
ceux qui travaillent et qui vont tourner
la vieille que de mig notre nation eh
bien nous nous sommes fiers madame
trouvé avec notre politique économique
d'avoir créé des emplois avoir connu la
montée des inégalités de nous approcher
du plein emploi de pouvoir financer
enfin nos prestations sociales car avant
de redistribuer les richesses madame
trouver il faut les produire c'est ce
que vous avez oublié
je vous remercie madame trouvé
est bien la bonne je m'appelle madame
trouver nous sommes fiers de taxer les
plus riches pour partager les richesses
monsieur bruno le maire
la parole est un monsieur m'a fait rater
merci merci madame la présidente chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre du travail du plein
emploi et de l'insertion monsieur le
ministre dans une récente enquête 83%
des chefs d'entreprise il sait faire
face à des pénuries de compétences et à
des recrutements de plus en plus
difficile ceci résulte bien sûr du
dynamisme du marché du travail qui a vu
le chômage reculer jusqu'à près de 7%
soit son plus bas niveau depuis 15 ans
il ya cinq ans monsieur le ministre nous
parlions surtout du chômage aujourd'hui
nous parlons des difficultés des
entreprises à recruter et c'est un
progrès considérable
et lorsqu'elles deviennent trop
importantes ces difficultés de
recrutement pénalise pas simplement les
en propre les entrepreneurs elle
pénalise aussi les français dans leur
vie quotidienne dans le secteur du
bâtiment cela signifie concrètement des
chantiers qui s'allongent et beaucoup de
nos concitoyens qui attend depuis
longtemps de voir leurs logements
terminés rénové au mieux isoler dans le
secteur des services à la personne ce
sont par exemple des parents qui se
voient refuser une place en crèche pour
leurs enfants faute de personnels
qualifiés pour les accueillir dans le
secteur automobile
ce sont des délais qui s'allongent avant
d'obtenir un rendez-vous pour réparer
son véhicule est alors que nombre de nos
concitoyens nous le savons dépendent de
leur voiture pour aller travailler
les difficultés de recrutement sont donc
un problème majeur qui touche tous les
secteurs tous les territoires et qui
ralentit la marche de notre pays vers le
plein emploi les postes non pourvus ce
sont des emplois en moins et donc des
ressources en moins pour nos écoles pour
notre système de soins pour notre
justice et pour bien d'autres domaines
essentiels de l'action publique sur ce
sujet beaucoup a été fait ces dernières
années en particulier pour orienter et
former des apprentis vers les métiers
qui recrutent mais il faut désormais
aller plus loin pouvez vous donc nous
indiquait monsieur le ministre ce que le
gouvernement entend faire pour aider les
entreprises à recruter en particulier
les plus petites d'entre elles je vous
remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à
monsieur olivier du choc le ministre du
travail plein emploi et de l'insertion
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
ferracci le constat que vous dressez et
partager les entreprises ont une
principale difficulté aujourd'hui c'est
recruter c'est recruter parce que le
taux de chômage est au plus bas vous
l'avez dit c'est recruter parce que le
taux d'emploi est le plus élevé c'est
recruter parce que cet objectif de plein
emploi qui avait disparu de notre
vocabulaire qui paraissait comme une
auto qui est devenu une réalité en tout
cas une perspective est un objectif nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans une situation où
le chômage est assez dire qu'il 3% notre
objectif d'aller à 7% et nous savons que
nous devons accompagner les recrutements
et aider les entreprises à faire face à
ses difficultés ça prend plusieurs
formes la première c'est le plan de
réduction des tensions de recrutement
mise en oeuvre en octobre 2021 1
milliard 400 millions d'euros mobilisés
à la fois pour former des salariés dans
les entreprises et leur donner des
compétences nouvelles permettant aux
entreprises de développer mais surtout
former les demandeurs d'emploi pour
faire en sorte que leurs compétences
répondent aux besoins de l'économie et
des recrutements ce sont avec ce plan
deux cent cinquante mille demandeurs
d'emploi de longue durée qui sont
revenus vers l'emploi c'est un million
quatre cent mille offres d'emploi chez
pôle emploi pourvu 200 milles dans le
secteur de l'hôtellerie des cafés des
restaurants malgré les difficultés de
recrutement 260 milles dans le service à
la personne dans des secteurs qui sont
connus pour des difficultés de
recrutement mais ces difficultés ne
doivent pas cacher que ce sont des
secteurs en expansion dans le secteur
des hôtels cafés restaurants en avril
2022 le nombre de salariés 5% supérieur
à ce que nous connaissions en avril 2019
lorsqu'on associe la création de 150
mille emplois et
c'était sort dans ces secteurs là ça
explique les difficultés que
pouvons-nous faire d'abord agir à court
terme madame la première ministre m'a
demandé de préparer une suite au plan de
réduction des tensions d'accentuer nos
efforts de les accélérer et de se
concentrer sur les secteurs les plus en
difficulté nous devons aussi travailler
dans le temps et travailler dans le
temps c'est sous m une discussion aux
partenaires sociaux pour faire en sorte
que les règles de l'assurance chômage
soit plus incitative à la reprise
d'emploi il ya des pays qui ont des
systèmes incitatifs lorsque le marché de
l'emploi va bien et plus souple plus
protectrice lorsque le marché de
l'emploi se dégrade nous devons nous en
inspirer c'est aussi créer france
travail pour faire en sorte qu'il ya un
interclubs leur unique de l'accueil
jusqu'à lac salon merci beaucoup la
séance des questions au gouvernement est
terminée je vous remercie